Senator Bob Menendez he's a Democrat he
has just been indicted on bribery
charges for accepting gold bars this is
going to be an interesting story because
this dude's been he's been uh I think
he's been criminally charged before he's
been let's just say he's been on the
wrong side of the law in the past
and uh here we go again I don't think
anyone's surprised to hear this news but
it's gonna have a tremendous impact on
the Senate I'm wondering what this will
mean for New Jersey and for the balance
of power in the Senate and then of
course we have that we have a the
Democrat mayor of Dallas
switches to the Republican Party
this is going to be really interesting
what we see moving forward in 2024 of
course we've been seeing a lot of
interesting things there's no not
necessarily any evidence of direct
correlation but when you see someone in
a Democrat City say outright we need
Republicans I'm switching that's it I
think 2024 is going to get really
interesting in terms of people are
insane there's going to be prosecutions
there's going to be conflict but we're
going to see weird stories in the press
and uh well may you live in interesting
times before we get started with the
news my friends head over to timcast.com
click timcast irlx Miami and pick up
your tickets to come see us in Miami
October 6th with Patrick Bet David James
O'Keefe Matt Gates lucrutkowski of
course me and Ian Crossland will be
there plus a whole bunch of other guests
will be there as well we've got Alex
Stein he'll be doing a set just before
the show and uh several other prominent
individuals that you're fans of that
have appeared on Tim cast iron are going
to be hanging out and uh we might have a
list of uh scheduled attendees uh next
week but pick up your tickets now we
hope to see you there don't forget to
also click join us become a member so
that you can hang out in the Discord
server with all the other like-minded
like-minded individuals the Tim the
timcast Discord members are running
pre-shows after shows they're making
music together they're working on
projects together it really is a great
community of people doing awesome work
so sign up you also get access to a
massive library of uncensored members
only shows dating back to I think two
two or so years now we do those Monday
through Thursday you don't miss them and
more importantly as a member you're
supporting our work your membership when
you sign up it helps support our
infrastructure and it allows us to do
crazy things like build an anti-time
Square which is currently underway we
are working with Chef Andrew gruel on
the plans we are going the idea is to
create this big parallel economy
physical space we've got a bunch of
really awesome stuff happening and of
course shout out to Public Square
because uh they've sponsored our Miami
event and we hope to do a lot of really
awesome stuff with them in building the
parallel economy and additionally as
members the payment processor we use for
timcast.com it is parallel economy it is
a rumble affiliate it's Dan bongino
these guys are are doing amazing things
in building infrastructure so that we
can't get banned or canceled not
impervious but more resilient smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
share the share with your friends
joining us tonight to talk about this
and a whole lot more is Vince Dow
good to see everyone yeah my name is
Vince Dao I'm a gen Z conservative
content creator and you may recognize me
from that one Vice panel where the other
Asians were going crazy and I just was
very calm and everyone was seeing that
not everyone but a lot of people in the
sector have seen that so if you've seen
that that's of course me and um you know
great to be here and Good To Be With You
Tim of course right on thanks for
hanging out we got Phil Labonte hello
everybody my name is Phil Labonte lead
singer of All That Remains a failed
musician guy anti-communist encounter
revolutionary a communist a communist
called you a failed musician is that's
not a communist he's a socialist ah it's
the same garbage you know socialism so
the the end goal of socialism is
communism said Lenin uh this is like uh
dude yeah so Hassan was uh doing a
podcast and he said Phil was a failed
musician and it's like bro if you're
that desperate and that's the only move
you have to make against someone because
you don't have an argument to say that a
platinum recording artist who just
opened for Metallica has failed I'm like
man what's success uh apparently it's uh
quitting The Leftovers is success is
what I hear so that's what I hear I
don't know for sure but I hear that he
was leaving the leftovers but the
leftover I mean look Ethan Klein gave
him the business and that was the thing
that I was poking at him about and then
the very next uh how do you get
destroyed by Ethan Klein I mean it was
it was well he asked two questions about
uh communist China and you're afraid of
your chat he's terrified of his chat and
he doesn't want to say anything too uh
anti-china so you know and then the
whole next episode I watched it just
just recently
um they just Ethan and Hassan are just
are Ethan's picking Hassan apart and wow
yeah his son's socialism is not strong
yeah yeah wow that's true well Ian's
here hey everybody what's up you can
cross on I'd love to get Hassan in the
house we've been meaning to have him on
anyway so maybe now's a good time get
this all hashed out face to face
some music together well he of course is
always welcome I just really don't see
that as being a reality that'd be great
it would be cool to get him here I mean
he was the Bro Bible guy like I feel
like somewhere deep down there's you can
have a real conversation but if
someone's if someone's built their
career off making money and their whole
plan is like what kind of content can I
do to make money there's apparently some
Scandal involving Don Mulvaney related
to this like a video came out but we've
talked about it before where if you look
at Dylan's early content it's like
throwing spaghetti at the wall and
seeing what sticks yeah you know these
people aren't going to betray an
ideology when the whole purpose of their
ideology is to make money yeah you know
but anyway and I hate the term grifter
but I've seen Hassan just sit there and
he'll react to stuff and basically just
eats food the whole time says a couple
comments and it sells because it's the
reaction content I don't know yeah so
boys
you know I mean the the real secret is
for a lot of uh these online communities
it's a place to hang out exactly exactly
but let's uh let's jump into the news
ladies and gentlemen Bob Menendez has
been charged with accepting gold bar
bribes hey man I gotta say if you're
gonna take bribes gold bars is the way
to do it smart so uh New Jersey Senator
Bob Menendez has been indicted for
bribery according to a statement from
the United States Attorney for the
southern district of New York Menendez
is currently the chairman of the Senate
Foreign Relations Committee the Democrat
and his wife Nadine have been under
federal investigation since 2022. the
couple's allegedly believed to have
taken four hundred thousand dollars
worth of gold bars from New Jersey
developer and former bank chairman Fred
dayabis how do you pronounce it diabs
and his associates while Hannah and Jose
Uribe in exchange Menendez reportedly
agreed to use his official influence to
sway the justice department which had
accused diabus I don't know how to
pronounce that base
of Bank crimes newly unsealed documents
filed in New York accused Menendez and
his wife of accepting hundreds of
thousands of thousand bribes in exchange
raising menendez's power and influence
as a senator to seek protect and enrich
Hannah how do you pronounce that your
Arabi Arabia yes
it looks like and diabetes that there's
a little um typo there it's just d-a-i
instead of to the benefit of the Arab
Republic of Egypt wow well the first
thing I'm going to say is the federal
government especially the southern
district of New York gets zero benefit
of the debt from me and I gotta say I I
I am biased against you know individuals
like Menendez and many Democrats but I
will tell you this I am more biased
against the southern district of New
York for the things they've done aren't
they the ones that have been going after
they went to project Veritas maybe I'm
wrong about that but I know that they're
they're going after Trump not a fan of
these guys and so I will actually say
you know I'll give Menendez the benefit
of the doubt let's let's hear what hear
what they say first and foremost no
matter who someone is innocent until
proven guilty but uh I am not going to
jump on throwing Menendez under the bus
simply because he's a Democrat I do not
trust sdny I do not trust Federal
prosecutors I think the moment the feds
tried the and New York goes after Trump
for political reasons anything they do
is Tainted no matter what so maybe they
want to go after Menendez fine maybe it
benefits Republicans in the long run
sure whatever don't care these people
are evil and I don't trust them do you
guys have a gold sponsor because if you
do this would be a great time you know
hey the politics are trying to on the
podcast take the gold okay so what what
what do you think you should be doing no
but uh yeah I mean it's interesting
there probably has to be a reason
they're going after him I'd have to
imagine I mean you've seen the same
thing you said southern district of New
York right you kind of saw how the
political system in New York went after
Andrew Cuomo one of their own because
you know clearly something there fell
out of favor so I really wonder what the
the backstory is here because I couldn't
imagine they're just gonna go after him
just because oh he's a corrupt
politician right so there's probably
something more to the story I would have
to imagine all Menendez has to do right
now is put out a press conf have a press
conference and say that one week ago he
began drafting a resolution for the
Senate to end the persecution and
prosecution of Donald Trump because it
was disruptive to our democracy and then
all of a sudden he's being indicted and
just let her rip yeah interesting I mean
because look
the Democrats are on the seat of power
yeah what could he say right now in
favor of Democrats that would get
Democrat and nothing if he came out and
said I hate Donald Trump please they'd
be like too bad we don't care yeah but
if he came out and was like I wanted to
I I was arguing to end the prosecution
of trump because this is not the way the
Democratic party should be operating
that would actually earn him some
benefit people he would get political
tribalist being like we'll let you slide
on this one keep talking
I I don't really have a take uh other
than you know if you can get gold bars
get them I'm very glad you started off
the segment talking about the
presumption of innocence that's a real
important part of the next 20 or 30
years of American livelihood yeah but
the problem is we we be good people so I
will I have no problem saying like I
don't know what this guy was involved in
but you better prove it before I'm
willing to throw someone in jail or
whatever every day beyond but the
problem is the Democrats don't extend
that in their Direction no so it so at
this point is it like well you know what
you stick that label on your name and
you get you get no favors from me no
that that's what they I think that's
what deep the Deep power wants is for us
to forego rule of law and just start
going at each other they're frothing
waiting for you but they're using the
law like to go if you're not I don't I
don't see how you get to foregoing the
rule of law like if you are pro if he's
being prosecuted by New York they're you
know they're using the law against him
now granted I mean it looks like it
doesn't look good it looks it looks like
he actually did this stuff but that
being said you should be innocent until
proven guilty you know or you should be
treated that way but it's not like it's
not like they're after like it's not
like there's there's an attempt to get
around the law or circumvent the law
except for on his his case I don't see
that that it's a right left thing is
what I guess is what I'm going to do
here's the thing is that I don't even
want to use the term Democrats I think
it's more so there's a lot of people in
the uni party who have gotten away with
genuine legitimate crimes that you know
no one ever indicted no one ever tried
to even investigate so I do think to
some degree considering what they're
doing to Trump and you know a lot of
people on our side for very frivolous
reasons very often I do think in the
future if we ever want to kind of
balance out the playing field I do think
you're gonna have to at some point try
to hold the other side or the unit party
I should say really more so accountable
for the things that they're just
straight up getting away with that are
real crime so I'm not saying obviously
fabricate crimes or try to you know just
go after people to go after them but I
think you've seen them turn a blind eye
to a lot of uh establishment politicians
over the years and I think
to balance out the situation now I think
you know
look and it's not just it's probably not
going to happen but it's just uh you
know in in theory they ignore Epstein
right all of them do not and and the
problem I have is that for a lot of
these powerful corrupt individuals that
we know about any prosecutor could have
got after them absolutely yeah yeah
there is justification for when it comes
to these politicians and high profile
individuals they do work in the
jurisdictions and jurisdictions all
across the country yeah there there's
there are grounds for it that's why New
York is going after Trump they'll find a
way but Republicans don't do I was
thinking last night like if you um tear
open an evil system and you rip back the
curtain and show everyone how evil it is
you're you're you're providing a threat
for the system stability even if it's
evil if you expose it it can disrupt and
then the system could fall apart so what
will happen is people will try and just
show you a little bit of it at a time
but that's like poking a needle into a
balloon and trying to to stop it from
popping trying to hold it tight and it's
like once evil gets exposed a little the
rest of it just comes pouring out and
like trying to suppress people's
awareness of it is almost doing more
damage to the system than just letting
it you know building up yeah that's what
it feels like there is there is a
posture full of pus on the United States
that they just keep slapping Band-Aids
over and it just keeps getting bigger
and worse yeah and when this thing pops
oh it's gonna suck but man you can't
just keep thinking like this is what
they do in terms of the economy as we
were talking about with debt and War and
one of the theories uh there there is a
theory I could call it conspiracy I
don't know if it's a conspiracy theory
hypothesis that the purpose of the
stimulus during covid was not really
coveted it was hey here's our chance to
flood the flood the economy with with
printed money so that we can pay down
the debt and kick the can down the road
for a couple more years because a
monetary system which produces more debt
than currency eventually collapses
I mean well that's something that that
austrians and Libertarians and even
fiscal conservatives have been talking
about I mean we are in a new paradigm
now considering the fact that the the
government and the Federal Reserve is
working under a modern monetary you know
Theory like so it's mmt all the way the
idea that they're taxing to pay for
things that's something that people
should
just put out of their heads the point of
taxes is to control inflation that's it
just to take money from people they're
gonna you they're going to print up the
money that they that they you know
whatever they need to do whatever that
whatever uh program they want whatever
they need they just print it the fact
that they're the the federal government
collects taxes means that the dollar has
a value because you have to get dollars
to pay those taxes they use taxes and
interest rates control to control
inflation there is nothing backing it
the only value that comes from your
dollar is is from the demand for taxes
so the we have to get away or people
should try to get away from the idea
that we are using taxes to pay for
projects and the the argument against
mmt is it gives the government
unlimited authority to print money and
do whatever they want with finances
outside of of the let me let me let me
let me read some of this real quick from
NBC just to give some context apparently
his wife is also being charged and they
say that federal agent said they
discovered many of the items many of
these items were when they executed
search warrants in the couple's home
they found more than 480 000 in cash
much of it stuffed into envelopes and
hidden in clothing closets and a safe
including jackets to bring the Senator's
name that were hanging his closet as
well as more than seventy thousand
dollars in Nadine's safe deposit box the
indictment alleges I mean this is pretty
this is pretty well whose money was he
holding they got photos yeah of like a
sweater let me let me pull this up
because I was just reading it on my
phone let me pull it up is there I
wanted to ask you Phil do you know if
any historical examples of a Nation or
an empire being in the level of debt
that we are no right now so this is kind
of like Uncharted Territory no and also
mmt is still a fairly new Theory yeah so
you did you guys yeah yeah I wanted to
comment really quickly on uh Tim's
quote-unquote conspiracy theory it's
funny we talk about the great reset
living in pods and very often the
natural reaction is people would never
accept that but that is the thing is
that when everything becomes
unaffordable when you can't afford a
home what are you going to live you
can't afford food you know what's what's
the next reaction to that so if it all
lined up and that was the purpose of
covid to basically destroy the current
Order In traditional American way of
life in so that way it gets worse and
worse and now eventually people 10 years
from now will basically just accept a
quasi-grate reset I think it's uh
interesting to say the least right I I
wanna I we got this picture pulled up
and it is
it's a decent amount of money I mean
it's probably a couple Grand serious
question though for like for what reason
honest question I'm not saying I'm not
it's not rhetorical honest question for
what purpose
would someone have five to ten thousand
dollars and hundred dollar bills and
envelopes hidden in this just like
stuffed in the pocket in a closet in a
sweater it's not his that's what I
that's my initial thought is whose money
is this and why is he holding on to it I
think he's a scapegoat I think they've
thrown him under the rug saying look the
doj plays fair look at us I mean it
could be his money because if he is
taking bribes it makes sense he doesn't
want a paper trail absolutely he does
hard paper but we live in a world of
crypto like I think it's very crypto's
not safe yeah they got AI that can track
all that this guy's been hard this guy
was notoriously uh pushing hard against
one of the crypto uh companies uh was he
like a year ago I read that earlier
today and I didn't didn't dig into uh
how bad it was but it's like it's like
uh you know harmonious that this guy
who's anti-crypto is taking bribes so
like
what you know who's the real villain in
this situation yo look at these gold
bars wow
gold bars what do you do with gold bars
put them in a safe it says Swiss band
Corporation I know but like
look man I know gold is valuable but
how are you going to move this amount of
money like what's your plan if you're a
regular person and you're like I would
like to hedge you know have a hedge or
or you know a hard asset or whatever
it's like oh I totally get it totally
get buying gold I have a little bit I
have most more silver than gold but no
makes sense but if you're taking bribes
what are you gonna do with it there was
a bunch in lots of envelopes different
envelopes that makes me think that
they're gonna traffic them they're going
to start trafficking cash off site they
may have already started trafficking
cash off site if they're in little
envelopes well I mean you know what's
kind of funny about this though is this
is a very old school New York New Jersey
political Scandal he has a bunch of Cash
Money gold bars Mafia very aesthetic
going there uh you know it kind of
amuses me to tell you the truth it's an
old school political it's very like
Breaking Bad Ozark right you know right
yeah that's funny
oh yeah so this is uh Menendez was going
hard on Venezuela's uh talk of
involving utilizing crypto okay now I I
I got I just gotta say right here nah
this doesn't move move the needle for me
I mean he's got a couple Grand in 50s
he's got 20s right there and it looks
like it might be like
so say 1400 1400 Maybe
in 20s
if they're super rich
having like a thousand bucks in a pocket
somewhere a couple like I'm okay I I can
understand that for whatever but that
stack of hundreds I'm like
for what for what purpose well it's now
the in the envelopes because if a drug
dealer has like a big block of weed
that's one thing but if they have a
bunch of little baggies of it all split
up that's intent to sell that's intent
to move basically
is I mean how rich is this guy what's
his net worth I don't know I'm not
really I don't really buy that he was
attempting to move the money I think he
was just sitting on it honestly I I have
a feeling you know if you're if you've
got gold bars like what what is it what
is move mean to you give it to his
friends send it overseas I'm not sure
put it in a pocket every time every week
all right all right hold on we got
opensecrets.org saying that his net
worth as of 2018 was five hundred and
forty one thousand dollars
Ain't No Way Ain't No Way someone who's
net whose net worth is just a half a
mill is drop in 510k in the coat pocket
and ignoring it if this dude was worth a
couple mil I'd be like maybe it was out
partying with the boys at a bar he took
out a bunch of cash maybe he was doing
Vegas or whatever I don't know there's
there's you I mean you know there's
reasons but not a dude who's worth this
and his assets are apparently his house
so he's worth half a million dollars but
375 is his house
and then he makes 170 75 000 a year that
is weird for him to be worth so little
money honestly from from I don't think I
can't believe this right where like he's
a New York but they got to file their
disclosures though yeah okay hold on
here uh I don't know what CA Club India
it says his net worth is 18 million oh
my gosh okay but I don't know which ones
which one's real I know that he's got to
uh uh you've got well the open Secrets
was 2018 right so right it was a while
to change yeah I mean wow being uh being
in government makes you a lot of money
apparently you know according to what is
wealthypersons.com Bob Menendez Googled
how much is one kilo of gold worth
around the time his wife accepted
alleged bribes
wow I Google that uh probably once a
week to check on the price and you guys
know that um
MSNBC host and it's all his wife imagine
imagine your wife his daughter his
daughter as a host on MSNBC I'm pretty
sure really yeah
daughter who do you guys know who gave
the bribe alleged bribe does it say in
the article it doesn't I don't think so
Bob Menendez is Alicia
let's see uh yeah uh Alicia Alicia
Menendez uh anchor for MSNBC is she
still I think
uh she's how she has hosted uh well I'm
pretty sure she does stuff for them but
you know is it any as any surprise to to
to like it's it's one big happy family
tree everybody you know this is what
they do yeah
granted I'll say it again like innocent
until proven guilty you know what I mean
I I don't care for this they bombing is
Googling how much is a kilo of gold
worth doesn't prove that he took a bribe
right like for all we know his wife
bought gold and they were like we're
gonna get rid of this guy because he's
not playing ball with us yeah I don't I
don't trust Bob Menendez I mean he's
been accused of a lot of things before
and so I'm not giving I mean first of
all for the most part Democrats ain't
getting the benefit of the doubt from me
right you know well that's the thing is
the system is so corrupt these days that
it shouldn't be like this but the minute
I see them go after someone yeah exactly
the minute I see them go after someone
my first instinct isn't okay what do
they do in the terms of the crime it's
why are they going after him right and I
think that's kind of a natural reaction
we have in a lot of American life these
days you know let's let's let's let's
start with I want to jump to the story
from CNN Dallas mayor switches parties
to join GOP all right we just covered a
story about a Democrat being accused
taking bribes being corrupt and uh I
think for most of you who watch our show
you probably don't have a very favorable
view of Democrats nor the majority of
the Republican Party
but the Democrats I I widely view as
corrupt tribalists who are just career
politicians who are trying to extract
what they can from the system
and so here you have this guy this is
Dallas mayor Eric Johnson responding to
questions during a news conference and
there are two issues that are brought up
because of this let me read a little bit
Dallas mayor Eric Johnson announced
Friday that he's switching parties and
will serve as a republican Affiliated
mayor of the blue leaning City while the
Dallas mayoral office is nonpartisan
Johnson previously served as a democrat
in the Texas legislative legislature he
slammed his former party in an op-ed for
the Wall Street Journal published Friday
blaming Democratic policies for
exacerbated crime and homelessness quote
the future of America's great Urban
centers depends on the willingness of
the nation's Mayors to Champion Law and
Order and practice fiscal conservatism
our cities desperately need the genuine
commitments to these principles as
opposed to the inconsistent poll-driven
commitment of many Democrats that has
long been a defining characteristic of
the GOP so to clarify
the mayoral position is not a partisan
position so they usually don't say like
the mayor's affiliation but he is he he
was a Democrat he ran you know in in in
this style this affiliation now he's
saying he is going to be joining the GOP
and will be Republican affiliate as
mayor
the question I have is first
if someone is a is a in a Democrat city
as as a high-level politician and
they're going to switch to the GOP
either they're saying I'm retiring or
they believe this is their their path to
maintaining their position and serving
their constituents secondly
this is a black mayor in a Democrat City
saying he's going to vote Republican and
we have more polling coming out from the
Wall Street Journal uh publishing the
monster journal and several other
outlets showing that Trump is polling
very very well among Black and Hispanic
Americans I'm wondering if this is
Indica if this is a component of this as
well if this is an another individual
who is pulled and it's outright saying
no more Democrat now a republican I have
a feeling that this is that the
conditions at the border are a
significant factor in why the Dallas
mayor is switching sides I I can't see I
can't imagine that the people of Texas
who are the most immediately affected by
the the Border crisis I can't see them
saying Oh it's fine I can't see them
saying Oh it's no big deal these people
that live in Texas like they know they
have friends that are in the in the
Border region and stuff like that
I mean granted Texas is a big state but
still like these people are living with
it every day and you see videos all the
time of of Caravans of people coming to
the Border I just read a a piece that
said 300 there was a there was a a
record that 300 000 people cross the
border or were uh detained or
apprehended maybe is the best word uh
300 000 people in one month it's a
record I mean the federal government is
totally
abdicated their responsibility with that
of of securing the border the the clown
Administration that we have put Kamala
Harris in charge and she hasn't done
anything at all they tried to deal with
the uh the the dude what's his name not
Mendes
um he was just on Capitol Hill talking
to the uh talking to Congress
uh they had a homelandic security either
way talking to him there's talking about
about impeaching him I think his name is
Americus yeah talking about impeaching
him and I don't know if anything's been
done but he has not done his job I I
think I here's how I see it there's that
Meme that I've brought up where it said
no one is trying to solve the problems
they're trying to get rich enough to
where the problems don't affect them and
I'm like that's a great motto for the
modern democratic party oh yeah help us
get rich enough so that your problems
are no longer our problems I wonder like
the problems affecting you won't affect
us is a better way to put it I wonder
what this means for 2024 because
obviously if you know anything about
Texas and the reason why people are
scared it's quote unquote going blue is
two major population growths it's in
Austin and Dallas right and so if you're
starting to see like Tim said is a
possibility which is he's actually maybe
doing it for a political reason because
he believes that the city of Dallas is
going to become more right-wing I could
see that translating to the rest of the
country too and I do think you're not
going to see demo Democrats do as well
in big cities as they did in 2020
because crime homelessness illegal
immigration all of it's adding up so I
wonder if there's something of an urban
a new Urban appeal for the Republican
party not to obviously win a majority of
any of these cities but at least to
crack you know I'm sure the Democrats
need a certain quota that way they can
outnumber the rural areas of a state
like Texas or Georgia or even Michigan
up in the Midwest states like that so I
wonder what it means for 2024 yeah I
really do the toxic compassion route has
failed them that's for sure like it
bring EVS many people unlimited more
more more people more people more people
then also you realize you're surrounded
by homeless people that that don't have
food there and you know it's interesting
I'm from Los Angeles you know most of
the family friends and stuff we grew up
with are Democrat but
I'm noticing a very real Trend in the
people I knew growing up now trending
I'd say more independent maybe moderate
maybe some even just have flat out
become Republicans because they're just
seeing it's too expensive crime you know
it's it's dangerous homelessness
everywhere we just can't do this anymore
so like I said I'm not going to sell
anyone here at delusion that oh my gosh
Republicans are going to suddenly flip
LA or California but like I said in
swing states where the big city is our
problem I think a few points off of
popularity for the Democrats could make
the difference in one of these states
you know in the presidential election I
don't know if uh the immigration would
be as heavy as it is without the
internet I don't know if the internet's
played a part in allowing this to happen
or if it's just allowed us to see what's
happening because I think if this had
happened without an internet it would be
happening without us knowing and then
all of a sudden one day we'd wake up and
there would be six 60 million people
from foreign countries in our country we
wouldn't know and they'd already be here
yeah controlling things now we can kind
of see it in real time and adjust and
maybe help prevent a catastrophe yeah
and I think people are willing to alter
their political parties at the very
least if that if they feel like that
might make a difference or maybe just
sit home you know I think that's another
issue you talk about black turnout I'm
not I don't think Republicans are going
to come close to winning a majority of
the black vote but I think a lot of
these people who they normally bust to
the polls and all that in the inner
cities might just say uh I don't really
care for this right now you know what I
mean
um so I think you could see that too
just a drop off and turnout of their
base even if it's not for us right right
right I think that's actually what the
polls uh show yeah that I should clarify
there are there are polls showing
conservatives improving but I think what
you actually see when you look at the
bigger picture is that this is sucked in
this yeah support for Democrats is way
down and support Republicans a little
bit right so there are some people are
like I'm gonna vote for the other guy
but most people are just saying I am not
voting Democrat there's no fuel there's
no fuel like people didn't vote for
Biden they voted against Trump right
right he's not the president right now
the president's Biden so if you're
feeling like life sucks right now you
got to look at President Biden and be
like he's not the guy anybody but him so
it may not be pro-trump people but
they're just like you're like like you
said they might just stay home they
might not go out and vote they're like I
can't vote for Trump but I'm not voting
for Biden and think about all the people
who you probably know people like this
that say if it's Trump versus Biden I'm
just going to leave that blank yeah that
helps Trump because Trump has a base in
Biden doesn't less so so yeah not only
has a base but he has disinfected
liberals yeah he there are a lot of
people who don't like Trump who will
vote for him because Trump's personality
issues and ego is nothing compared to
Biden's failures with the economy
foreign policy failures
Eastern European War these are these are
all just apocalyptic failures for our
president it's true it's and it's I mean
it is possible that he and Hunter Joe
Biden and Hunter Biden got us into this
war in the Middle East obviously Russia
you mean Ukraine
I called it the Middle East
all kind of one area you know Turkey is
turkey the Middle East it's right next
middle east of Europe yeah
um and it's like if they went there and
did some CR if Hunter went there and
then got bribe to be go on an energy
board for barisma and they were and then
Biden just was like yeah let's make some
money off this and then we got into a
war like that's the most true maybe not
treason maybe not treason but like
what's selling out the country for
sending the country into a war to make
profit I think it would be treason
but I guess treason is specifically
providing Aid to a foreign adversary in
time of War I think that I don't think
that it's that personal like I don't
think when it comes to the war in
Ukraine I think that there's a whole
apparatus that is interested in seeing
Russia uh you know hurt and seeing uh
well actually just mostly Russia hurt I
think the the support from Ukraine comes
from the United States saying it is
better for our foreign policy to have a
weaker Russia so when Russia decided
they wanted to attack Ukraine or invade
Ukraine the U.S said we will help
Ukraine we will keep feeding them arms
and essentially it's the same model
that you know you we use or the US used
when there were the Russians were in
Afghanistan right so you were feeding
arms and ammunition and money to the
mujahideen and they were fighting
Russians so that way the Russians would
feel the same pain that the U.S felt
when the U.S was in Vietnam fighting the
VC and that was being funded by the
Russians and the Chinese this is the
kind of thing that happens or has
happened uh regularly since the end of
World War II because the Russians in the
united or the US and Russia can't get
into an actual confrontation themselves
because it'll likely turn into a nuclear
war these kind of uh
military actions are horrible and you
see you know war crimes are being posted
on X every day I just saw one there's a
dude trying to surrender to a drone and
they keep dropping bombs on him because
well he's the bad guy well that's a war
crime if he's trying to surrender and
they keep dropping hand grenades on him
kill him that's a war crime and you see
this stuff all the time and it's normal
in these kind of uh well it's normal in
war and it's it really does benefit the
U.S
strategically to have Russia engaged in
a war and have Russia weakened by you
know having a bunch of people die it's
gotten so dark Phil like I'll watch
these videos and you see the people
gathered around the tablet flying this
drone and they're laughing because
they're disconnected from the Carnage
and the chaos they're causing to be fair
though if you if if someone invades the
United States all bets are off sure you
know if someone invades your country
like war crimes are for like people that
are in like in the US when they were in
World War II had to worry about war
crimes when they were in France right
nobody was looking at the French saying
you're committing war crimes because you
you know you're cutting Nazis heads off
or whatever well the Nazis invaded you
know that's what happens and that's what
tends to happen in war generally but it
doesn't make it you know doesn't make it
any less of a war crime well here's the
thing it's interesting you say you know
the US thinks it strategically helps us
to be funding this war whatever but I
would kind of make a counter argument to
that which is in many ways we pushed
Russia and Ukraine into to the spot you
kind of look at the history of the the
Minx Accords and stuff over the years
you know the United States has stepped
in repeatedly and told Ukraine don't
negotiate with Russia you know they kept
Fanning the Flames of this but then what
has happened now as a consequence of
that is Russia now in the moment may
look kind of stupid hey look their
Invasion isn't going so well
haha but what's long-term what's
long-term happening is Russia is being
back now into the corner of China and
you know they're all together now and
meeting and there's an alliance there
it's obviously forming people say oh
that's inevitable because they're both
authoritarians that's not true at all
when you look at the history of Russia
and China there's a reason why they've
actually been a little bit more isolated
and Putin's been nervous about going
into China's hands even when they were
both
communist right the Soviet Union and
Malice China didn't even get along
um and I think Putin's been in this
position the past few decades where he's
not sure do I want to be Western or
Eastern tries to play Both Sides we
could have potentially if not an ally at
least neutralized a very strong threat
in having uh Russia not on the side of
China and isolating China but instead
what we've done through the whole course
of basically in many ways I would argue
inciting this war and definitely feeling
the Flames of it is now long term we
have a very powerful axis that we
constructed ourselves and now we're
gonna have to fight at once and maybe
they want it yeah maybe they want it
they create they create a problem yeah
that gives them a crisis that they can
use to exploit and Implement new
policies plans but I'm gonna just err on
the side of stupidity over malice on
this one I agree I think that the
argument that a weak Russia makes a
strong U.S is flawed and I would argue
with any defense contract or any anyone
in the administration anyone wants to
talk because a a weakened Russia becomes
a desperate Russia and a desperate
Russia has nuclear weapons that's not
good for American sovereignty a strong
Russia has nuclear weapons too though
unless we are not concerned with their
nuclear weapons for some reason maybe
yeah that's true and also we think
Russia seeks allies elsewhere and we
don't want that doesn't make us strong
America and this is a little bit of an
unsecurity I heard that uh musk is
Contracting with the feds to build star
Shield or something which is essentially
the Iron Dome in the U.S starshield I
don't know if this is true I I it's it's
a rumor that I heard so I don't I don't
have any information on it I was from a
year ago
so SpaceX unveils star Shield a military
variation of starlink satellites secure
satellite networks digital Iron Dome
okay so that's so then this is just an
internet oh it's a security system well
it says security does that mean like
laser defense well I imagine it could be
if you've got multiple satellites that
are it's just it's just Starling for the
government okay it's it's an isolated
Network so that it protects the
government
to do Defending Your satellites I mean
in the near future you see there's
things up there that can space I mean
the thing is if you can get a a you know
a constellation of satellites similar to
starlink then you can identify you know
uh missiles that are that are being shot
from anywhere in the world you can pick
them up as they're they're getting off
the ground and the idea is hopefully you
can shoot them down before they get over
the us if you I mean they have big
lasers that they put in c5as that can
shoot down missiles and so if you can
get them before they actually try to
deliver their mervs or whatever that
might be that might be part of so I mean
this is low low orbit satellite is the
vehicle for these laser interception
systems so but how would they collect
and store enough power even with
satellite to store enough power for a
directed energy weapon is it's it's it's
insane it's going to be like years of
charging up I imagine that it can even
hold it I imagine that they're just to
identify and and notify the the US that
there is some kind of ground level thing
going on yeah when it takes off and then
like I said you put a C5 in the air with
a big uh chemical laser in it and they
you know because you can scramble if
it's got 30 minutes you can scramble the
C5 in 10 if you have them on standby get
them in the air and get them before
they're I kind of feel like they'd
probably just go the traditional Iron
Dome or Thad method which is launching
rockets and Rockets should be yeah or
could be yeah I mean maybe lasers is the
last resort but the range on them is not
going to be strong enough they're range
on the lasers yeah I mean by the time
there's enough power in the laser at
least based on what we understand the
nuke is already in a very damaging
radius of whatever the target is but if
they have these laser systems you know
strategically placed far outside of
Civilian or military areas okay then
perhaps but if we're talking about a
Merv from Russia which is going to be in
the stratosphere
I don't know man is that a plane to
intercept it and hope that the laser
mounted on you know that's what I think
it is I know that they do they they have
tested uh
lasers on you know mounted in big cargo
planes because they're they're massive
and they take up a lot of space and
they're chem they're chemical lasers if
I understand correctly
um but again I'm I'm not an expert at
all so this is this is me relating what
I've read
um so but it you know I imagine that
that would make you know Russia less of
a threat but I still don't think that uh
I wouldn't trust it anyway no well I
mean it's world war three you're gonna
count on your survival hey the
government built some lasers are gonna
um I don't think it would happen hosted
payloads it says on its website SpaceX
says star Shield will have an initial
focus on three areas imagery
Communications and quote hosted payloads
third of which effectively offers
government customers the company's
satellite bus the body of the spacecraft
as a flexible platform hmm But what is
that what does that mean like it's going
to carry something payload sounds like a
virus
a payload is is usually some kind of
weapon you know if you're talking about
the payload on a nuclear weapon that's
the that's the the Warhead would be the
payload so I don't know exactly what hey
look if the U.S this does real low orbit
ion cannon I'm not complaining great
this those are my actually but it's
funny this does remind me a lot of the
Star Wars stuff in the 1980s so I wonder
if this is actually a serious idea or
just you know bluffing like it was in
the 80s obviously with Reagan I don't
know he he had some for people and I'm
not familiar you had some plan some
crazy plan with Blazers whatever it is
yeah
to shoot down Russian nukes and the
whole thing was blunder uh Bluff but the
point of it I guess intuitively was what
I thought it was just that they didn't
have the technology at the time
well I think part of the reason they
talked it up that way was because they
wanted to get the Soviet Union to you
know run up their military budget and
basically blow up yeah now they have
hypersonically the Hypersonic Weaponry I
don't know enough about it it's actually
slower it's slower than regular nakano
oh why is it why is it touted as uh
indefensible then they're like we can't
shoot down our Hypersonic stuff because
they're talking about missiles where it
says ICBM actually goes into orbit and
to get into orbit it's 20 000 miles an
hour is that what you have to is how
fast you have to go something like that
to break Earth orbit whereas Hypersonic
would be you know uh what's the speed of
sound is 750 miles an hour it's five I
think they travel five times speed of
sound it has something to do with uh
Hypersonic missiles travel low closer to
the Earth and are harder to uh track and
respond to so with um icbms they go up
they go high they go fast but the higher
it goes with the curvature of the Earth
the the more the more range we have for
detecting them whereas hypersonics are
low and slow the escape velocity of
Earth is 33 times the speed of sound so
the a uh a Hypersonic missile is
actually significantly slower than an
ICBM okay
but yeah Hypersonic missiles so this is
uh check it out here you go Yep this is
from a couple days ago this is amazing
Hypersonic missile weapons are super
fast so you can see ballistic missiles
Hypersonic and cruise Hypersonic stays
low and is outside radar detection
before and then it's too late yeah this
is the US Navy is developing directed
Energy Systems as a potential defense
against Hypersonic it's a cool graphic
and uh that's military it's basically
aerospace.com talks about the Navy's
laser weapon defense and if they're
talking about laser weapon defense
openly then they've probably got some
nasty laser weapon defense
Star Wars Bluff like you're saying
earlier this is basically what my point
was you can see right here in the
graphic uh they don't show the the
graphic that I want I watched a while
ago about this shows the curvature of
the earth and explains why radio
detection is limited and it's because as
the Earth curves the radar goes out and
so there are certain areas where you're
not going to see anything at the ground
level and the hypersonics track closer
to the ground and then slam to the
Target before you realize it the Boeing
Yale one Airborne laser tested uh weapon
system was a megawatt class chemical
oxygen iodine laser mounted inside a
modified military Boeing 747 400 f it
was designed as a missile defense system
to destroy tactical ballistic missiles
while in boost phase I don't know if
it's actually
so apparently these hypersonics go 20
times the speed of sound so maybe wow
something could break anywhere on the
earth in a matter of hours yeah and it
was it in less than an hour holy crap in
less than one hour
man that's wild
you know one day there's going to be
like some prominent personality who's
leading the charge against war or
something and then before anyone even
realizes that there's gonna be a crater
where his house used to be and it's good
but we have no idea what happened no one
can see it I mean look Russia and it's
pretty clear that Russia shot down that
uhni guy they shot down his ocean yeah
they shot down his plane so I I imagine
that kind of technology in the hands of
a you know a regime like Russia or you
know some other uh less than Democratic
uh regime would do just that smoke
someone that is irritating them without
blood
but what if what if starshield is
actually radar detection
from space to track hypersonics that's
what I imagine so take a look at this
right they're showing right here in this
graphic that the signal the wave is
coming from the ground and going up and
the radar can't detect Beyond this uh
this this you know angle what if you had
a radar from space then you'd have the
inverse then it would be able to see
everything happening
like a spider web anything that comes in
you can pinpoint it with thousands of
satellites up there you know exactly
where it is now you've got space radar
in which cases hypersonics you can track
I like how the cruise missile just
doesn't make it anywhere it's just like
14 minutes it barely when was the cruise
missile invented how long ago was that
okay just I don't know I wonder I wonder
if that was uh that's probably still
after uh rocketry I mean V2
70s I imagine because they they were
using cruise misses were the first thing
I remember seeing when in the first Iraq
War I was 15 years old and like they'd
started shoving cruise missiles down
Saddam Hussein's neck and and it was it
was impressive you know as a kid to be
like whoa that's actually yeah you know
the missile that Trump dropped while he
was President the mother of all Moab it
was that a cruise missile no that's a
that is a gravity bomb they call it it's
a thermobaric bomb so it actually when
it hits the ground or when it when it
detonates first it shoots out a bunch of
uh gas that blows up oh interesting
ignites the gas it looks like the first
cruise missile was invented during World
War One by the Americans but it wasn't
used and during the interwar period not
many people were working on but Germany
went hard on on the rockets and I could
be wrong about the way that it works I
could be thinking of a different thing I
know the Moab is Big it was it's the
biggest munition that is not a nuclear
weapon then to clarify a cruise missile
specifically is a missile that's that's
uh supposed to hit a Target on land
that's the point of it that's why they
call it a cruise missile I guess
the Vengeance weapon
the venge v stands for vengeance the V2
rocket it's the
virgelton swap
where the V2s were the ones where the
British Pilots had to like tip them out
of the way right am I getting that one
right it was a Nazi I know that yeah
because they weren't that fast but it
was a completely new technology I don't
know you mean like with their plane so
they have to fly alongside it and then
you tip it with your wing and it's just
enough to Veer it out off its course
yeah you know it wasn't really that
effective from what I hear they just had
a lot of them and no one else did they
poured their research and development
into the video that was that was part of
Hitler's problem is he always wanted to
focus on very sci-fi-esque at the time
futuristic ideas instead of what was
practical and this was one of them you
know it just it didn't do the damage to
London and England that was worth all
the money they put into it yeah they
want to just rock it England all day
every day and then the nukes got
invented so everyone's saying V1 is the
the missile that I'm talking about it's
the predecessor to the V2 is the one the
British would just tip out of the way
with their own plane have you seen I
think the whole three then was the giant
gun right the Giant Cannon that went
from several miles and like I said it's
a cipher oh wow it's a giant gun you're
talking about the windows on a rail yeah
yeah and didn't they just blow it up or
whatever you can just bomb it
if you can in the German super gun
I've never heard of it either they had
this big cannon that was
ridiculously big it had to be moved on
Rail and and it was not practical
anything that you have to that has to be
like on rail to move that's completely
impractical and it's easy to bomb that's
easy to destroy yeah yeah before like
World War One when they just had hot air
balloons and stuff they were extremely
effective artillery on rail but now with
air support it's they're just targets
yeah I mean not just targets but they're
easily targetable from space and you
know I talk with a lot of confidence
about military Tech I'm not a military
guy I just want to put that out there I
I defer to anyone with combat experience
or that's an expert on the Weaponry
because I love hearing about this stuff
it's crazy
2754 civilians killed in London by V2
attacks and 6523 injured but see that's
not really a lot when you consider the
total death during the war and the
amount of money that went into that
versus the return that's the problem two
people per Rockets it's uh right that's
not a really good investment at all
they'd be better off putting rocks on
blimps and just having the Rocks fall I
mean you're you're right and we say that
demanded this with bombs yeah if you
think about think about the uh the
amount of money that was spent in Iraq
like every time that they shot a
Hellfire at like a goat herder you know
you because they do because it would
just be some random dude that got paid
you know whatever 100 bucks or whatever
to go up on the hill and with his old
1910 Springfield rifle or whatever take
a couple pot shots at the at the base
because the point is to just harass the
Americans and the Americans reply was
calling the helicopters and they just
started lighting up the whole Hillside
oh these are those uh bombs yeah they
yeah this is crazy Japan would send up
balloons carrying bombs that would ride
the jet stream for thousands of miles
and then eventually drop the bombs on
the United States and random locations
most of them just hit Fields though yeah
that's a problem with trying to do that
to the US especially it's such a spread
out country China was able to do it
again they found out a way to get a
balloon over us so
man that's crazy and I remember when I
was little I watched a documentary about
it and it was like it had this system
where if it started to go too low
pressure the pressure in the in the
balloon would you know be going uh down
and then it would cause a bag to drop
which would then make it go back up
where the pressure would expand and then
as it started to go back down it would
drop another go back up yeah and they
timed it through these mechanisms to
drop once it traveled a certain amount
of you know time to hit the United
States yeah I watched some video
apparently like some kids found a bomb
and hit it with a rock and it blew up
and killed him or something oh my gosh
well I mean like you're running through
the woods and you find an explosive
device kids are stupid that's sad part
about what's happened in Ukraine now too
I imagine the mind they're mining the
field it's just not only depleted
uranium rounds underground they're just
irradiating the soil but like just the
the land mines and stuff left over
drones that go Rogue that fly off and
they're like I don't know where it went
you know we didn't see it explode it's
just gone we don't know where it went
kid's gonna find that drone you know
like people are gonna find they're gonna
stumble across it oh here we go look at
this May 5th 1945 six civilians were
killed near Bly Oregon when they
discovered one of the balloon bombs in
Fremont National Forest becoming the
only fatalities from axis action in the
continental U.S during the war that's
not to say I think it only hit people
once yeah I guess they didn't hit him
right exactly this must have been the
story it's uh Reverend Archie Mitchell
and his pregnant wife drove up gearheart
mountain today with five of their Sunday
school students in a picnic when Archie
was parked in the car Elsie and the
children discovered a balloon and
carriage loaded with an anti-personnel
bomb on the ground a large explosion
occurred the four boys uh were killed
instantly while Elsie and Joan patsky
died from their wounds shortly after an
army investigation concluded the bomb
had likely been kicked or dropped and
that it had Lane undisturbed for about
one month before the incident so that's
what it was I was that must have been
what I had been watching so they kicked
it I guess the Assumption was the kids
ran up to and they're like hey look an
explosive and they kicked it and then it
blew up so and people got to understand
too there are undetonated bombs in in
southeast Asia oh boy be careful there's
a lot of there's a lot of places
um I had a friend who went to Cambodia
and uh
was working with uh like the these uh I
I don't know I don't remember the exact
story but he was talking about how there
are landmines everywhere and to navigate
these fields there are footsteps and
you're jumping from footstep to footstep
in the dirt because you know it's the
only place that's the only way you know
that you're safe and you won't blow up
and I was talking about going I was like
yeah we were thinking of going because
there are these people who are doing uh
what they do is they release goats into
these fields and then the goats explode
and so I was like that's a crazy story
and I want to cover that and my friend
was like don't do it it was like the
scariest most stressful disturbing thing
in my life was traversing these fields
you don't want to do it trust me and we
end up not doing it but that's the
general idea however the tank Buster
mines require the weight of a vehicle to
detonate and so those are a lot harder
to trigger and they're huge but for the
smaller landmines they just will get a
bunch of goats and Field's all yours and
then boom boom boom the goats aren't
exploding crazy yeah rough yeah they do
another thing now where they have these
big uh they're take a big ball and
there's a bunch of bamboo uh sticks
coming out with plates on the bottom so
it looks like remember those suction cup
balls you'd throw the wall and then it
would suction cup its way down yeah yeah
they look like that and they the wind
blows them around and they just blow up
as they bounce around on land mines
because they're pretty heavy
yeah and then they just get damaged and
keep going until eventually they fall
apart I would I'm thinking that you
could maybe vibrate the soil and Trigger
them all at once if you could somehow
set up like Tesla was working on sending
electrical they're mechanical I mean
you're not I would say you're on the
right track you would need to heat them
up substantially and detonate them
somehow I would not do that maybe uh
plane flying not too high up just doing
a laser sweep or something or like stick
metal poles in the ground all over the
place and then send a low frequency
through or just yes
you can navigate a field to stick poles
in the ground yeah how big is it you
know how
how much space do you need to trigger
explosives I'm telling you more
explosives you won't you will not
convince someone to invest in any of
this technology when they can send goats
into a field I'm sorry dude they're
going to be like we got too many goats
already send them in how much oh I mean
yeah but I mean for the region it's
ghosts you know and then the goats just
blow up or like an S A Strategic Defense
from above where you can like you can't
see use lidar to map the ground and see
where they are and then hit them with
lasers I mean I suppose yeah but you're
talking about expensive and high-tech
and stuff it's easier to go you're gonna
you're gonna go to the government we can
spend two million dollars in Ohio maybe
we got two million dollars for lidar or
ten thousand for a bunch of goats
they're gonna be like just do the goats
can I eat the goats when it's done yeah
you're not gonna want to pick those
things up you can't you not I mean what
if they missed a mine you don't go into
minefields like minefields are like
there's an argue a significant argument
against mines like it they get left and
behind they end up naming kids you see
you saw it through all kinds of uh mines
that were left behind in after Vietnam
and stuff like that and and it it just
ruins entire regions and you have
massive amounts of death and dismembered
people and stuff and it sucks but
what do you do when you've got tanks
coming in you you're coming at you you
know like there's only so much so many
things that can stop a tank you know if
you can if you can knock the Treads off
a tank but with a ma with a mine then
the Tank's vulnerable they have to get
out of the tank then you can shoot the
guys that are in the tank but
if you can't stop the tanks tanks are
gonna smoke you and your buddies so you
deal with what you got you know you have
to put Minds out to stop them you put
mines out to stop him because again war
is awful war crimes are only war crimes
if uh if if
you are the losers yeah yeah but you
know I guess the issue today is you
don't need tanks if you can convince so
while propaganda has been a key
component of War for the past hundred
plus years propaganda nowadays is um
it's it's it's a million times where we
were 100 years ago you take a look at
say a nuclear weapon a Merv 12 Warheads
1250 times more powerful than the the
bomb strapped on Hiroshima Nagasaki you
take a look at the explosive power and
then go back in time to the origin of
the first you know com the first time
someone ever discovered combustion or
combustible materials
and it's it's it's a thousand plus years
ago Chinese yeah
started with yeah and I forgot I forgot
what they were they were doing something
impractical with them they had little
Rockets they would use to scare people
or something because they would like fly
at you and then uh it took a thousand
years to get the point where we could
just blow up an entire city with one
bomb you take a look at propaganda and
we'd have to drop pamphlets from Planes
and in a hundred years we can beam our
thoughts into your brain no matter where
you are China has a massive apparatus
for manipulating the American public in
Tick Tock for the record it was a 1044
A.D when gunpowder was invented in China
and what was it for did they say uh it
was four wasn't it for firecrackers just
to no but I think there was like
invented as at by accident they were
trying to make an elixir of immortality
this is according to Chinese sources
well most most discoveries are they're
called first known instances discoveries
because it was an accident so that
that's like the Moonshine thing where
they're making moonshine and then they
blow up you know that kind of cliche I
guess it started in China they were
trying to live forever so it's it's 80
808 A.D was the first reference yeah
that's what it says on Wikipedia yeah in
the Warring States period they had they
had rifles they weren't very good
archers were actually Flying Cloud
Thunderclap erupter hmm
so right I think it was uh yeah they
were they were shooting stuff out of it
yeah I don't know I read something that
like the initial stuff they did was just
like shock and awe they didn't really
have like a good way to weaponize it
yeah you still scare the horses that's a
big thing yeah
and the elephants if you have to fight
sulfur rialgar saltpeter and honey
smoking Flames results that the hands
and faces have been burnt and even the
whole house where they have been working
burnt down wow yeah that's crazy and the
Chinese invented the compass 1000 years
before Europeans did
crazy right nice they've been doing they
were doing all sorts of crazy stuff I
love this Chinese man they never really
they didn't really capitalize on on the
potential though like it it they did
well you know that's what's interesting
about as an Asian I can say this okay
about Asian culture is that very smart
yes but not a lot of creativity and
that's why even today you see throughout
also a lot of history right
Chinese invented gunpowder weren't using
it practically yeah who started using it
in a room because you had to think
outside the box you've never seen this
before right and there's a very Asian
culture of you know sort of this
submissive hey follow the strict line
you know do this do that but not a lot
of creativity and I think you see this
even in China for school if you want to
come to American school or whatever like
they'll just train your whole life to
take the SAT and you probably get a
perfect score but then what after that
what happens when you have to be say an
engineer and you have to actually think
creatively right and it's something
lacking in a lot of Asian culture I love
that for a thousand years they have
gunpowder these uh Southeast Asians
Chinese are like look at the stuff we
made look what happens when you light it
like whoa and then Europeans like
I could kill a lot of people with that
and then they were like wait what to be
fair the idea of killing people with it
did come from China I don't want to take
that away from them right they have
their their whatever it's called the
was it uh Hua long Jing what's that it's
that the Chinese military treaty what is
this uh oh this is an a flying cloud
Thunderclap erupter and it was like a
gun it looks like they loaded it with
powder they put a hole in it man that's
crazy Cannon like a shotgun yeah it's
like a cannon shotgun and it just shoots
like metal and rocks and stuff they
would just use yeah just
ballista I think uh George Washington
used to do that because they didn't
they're running low on munition so they
just shove whatever they could find into
the Cannons and just blast them so
you're getting hit with rocks sticks
pieces of metal but boot I gotta I gotta
tell you it is really crazy when you
think about it that's like the rare the
stupid stuff that we know from video
games and movies would make you a
warlord God like demigod in in a thought
2000 years ago or a thousand years ago
you'd show up and be like oh yeah I know
how to you know start a fire I know how
to like you know give me some bat crap
and we'll start making some gun puddle
by making what and then you'll you'll be
like what here eat this mold and you'll
feel better they're like what are you
talking about see that red rocket right
there see that red rock over there yeah
melt it what do you mean melt it just
light it on fire let's let's let's roll
and then it's like
all right look like I have no idea how
to make steel but I know it exists which
means I could go to them and be like you
need to like get carbon and iron and
start doing something and that is an
advancement Leaps and Bounds above how
long it took about like if just the fact
that I can tell I'm like oh you need uh
like bat crap you know just like
we know little bits here and there that
took humans thousands tens of thousands
of years to figure out and we just like
watched a movie once and we have
fragments of that information that if
you went back in time and said look man
I have no idea how to make gunpowder but
I saw something about bat crap once
you've just jumped someone up 10 years
20 years yeah so for real yeah what's in
the bat crap uh it begins with the G
potassium that crap is guano oh it's a
potassium uh
something potassium I'm not sure what it
is you mix you miss back crap with uh
uh bat crash we all know this because
salt peter and and
there was a uh manufacturing of the
metal that's crazy the caves in West
Virginia were used to manufacture our uh
Munitions for the Confederate Army bird
guano because they had a bunch of back
crap potassium nitrate and then charcoal
right that's what it is that's what it
is yeah so bird apparently works too oh
we got a bunch of chickens out there
could you make gunpowder from chicken
crap it smells like it it smells worse
than that dude all that that sulfur
coming off of it
yeah I don't know I guess you need to
get but anyway my point is to stress not
that I know how to make gunpowder or
anything like that just that we've got a
whole bunch of cursory knowledge like
even even just the fact that we know
things exist you go to something like
hey you can make a thing called a
compass where it's like I don't I don't
know how they made it but it was a piece
of metal and it was on a pin and it
pointed we had an n in one area and then
it would always Point North and then
someone's gonna figure it out very very
quickly relative to how long it took
humans to actually figure it out granted
you probably wouldn't be able to
communicate effectively with them you'd
say bat crap and they'd be like I have
no idea what he just said they would
hear you say Gobbledy they'd probably
just kill you before you got a chance oh
no for sure they'd be like strangely
dressed person you like if you go back
2000 years and you show and you show up
people like the first that happens is
they're pointing Spears at you screaming
at you in a language you don't
understand and then they're just like
yours life
I'm only going if I can bring a gun
that's it well have you seen you've seen
uh it was evil dead or was an Army of
Darkness which one was it my boom stick
yeah he goes back in time with the
shotgun this is my boom stick as the
change first what do you prime me it's
even touches me God what a great movie
tick I feel the uh how many I I would
love to talk about Evil Dead to be
honest it's a great movie man I I think
that the the heroes of Atlantis had the
compass my guess I don't want to take
the the show in the conspiracy town but
I I don't see how they could have
circumnavigated the globe with the Earth
on atlas's back without uh the compass
and then you know
the way that they seem to have colonized
Earth so what the importance of
preserving data because like we're
saying we have the data if we could go
back in time but they might have had it
back then it's the key is to be able to
preserve it probably in orbit in case a
comet wipes out the surface
in glass or something in orbit or in DNA
you can store data in DNA
all right
apparently people were saying online I
just did a quick charge that you can use
they call it chicken manure for
gunpowder too so if you've got chickens
but the bad Tim knew this that's why
there's chicken city outside no I I have
no idea how to extract saltpeter from
any of this stuff you you need like
alcohol or something uh you need
potassium nitrate sulfur and charcoal
but you need to to get the potassium
nitrate isolated you need alcohol or
something like that I don't know
and like I I don't even know how to make
alcohol apparently it's like you get
like wood alcohol or something I don't
even knows how to do this you talk about
going back it's crazy that people figure
this out hey let's take bat crab no no
but that's not how it is that's not how
it is it's uh so like bread for instance
like how does how does bread come to
exist some like people are Milling about
nomadic hungry they see wheat and they
rip the top they see horses eating the
tops and they're like hey look and they
pull out and they're like hey I can eat
this they start grabbing a whole bunch
of it bring it back home and then they
have a big they're like hey this stuff's
hard you can't eat it so they pull the
the you know the wheat grouts out put in
a big bowl and start eating them then
eventually someone like hey I'm gonna
heat mine up because you know I don't
like it cold and we we cook like humans
figure out cooking then they heat it up
then someone adds water to it then
someone matches it it's just slowly over
time and the first bread is just like
mashed grain they put water in it then
it made like a hard flat bread and then
eventually somebody let their sit out on
accident it's just always one step at a
time yeast contamination
somebody somebody probably was like oh
grandpa has no teeth he can't eat this
let's break it up for him so they mash
it no for real though they mash it up
then they put water in it and heat it
and they're like here you go and he's
eating warm warm dough paste and then
someone was like let's get it real hot
and then they saw what happened to it
and they're like look and then they're
like well now Grandpa can't eat it again
because now it's it's hard and they're
like whoa but then someone ate like hey
I like this then someone made the dough
left it out yeast contamination it got
really big and they're like and then
they cooked it and they were like oh
like you know it's just I think
penicillin was also found on accident
yeah of course it's all it look that's
why it's called Discovery when it's
discovered and not invention you know
what I mean or I mean I I often it is
called an invention but typically it's
Discovery we are discovering it it
exists and we stumble upon it like uh
Ben Franklin discovered electricity did
he really discover it he rediscovered it
I don't know I'm sure that I think Zeus
had it if he could shoot like I'm pretty
I'm pretty sure people had already been
using it I don't know that for sure the
Baghdad reproduced electricity it's a
clay pot filled with vinegar with a with
an iron rod in it wrapped with a copper
wire and then you can chain these pots
together and create electrical charge
that's like three thousand year old
technology at the least
I mean I gotta be honest hearing this
story about his kite experiment in 1750
1752 just sounds insane dude this man
this guy Ben
I mean this is this this is his country
man this is this country is formed in
this guy's belief structure this is the
guy that conceptualized the United
States of America
and they're like all right we'll let you
say that you discovered electricity I
kind of feel like Madison did that
because he's kind of the guy that's like
the father of the Constitution he wrote
the Constitution because he came before
everybody for 30 years and primed
everybody for it and like so this is it
he did not discover electricity he was
trying to prove that lightning was
electricity wow yeah and so they could
figure out a way to uh stop lightning
strikes and houses so they created
lightning rods which would then Focus
the lightning strikes away from the wood
and Woodstock blowing up houses
and but harnessing it that came later
harnessing it like I can't I don't think
so well no harm because electricity I
mean not not lightning just electricity
no they started making like I I I I
think they had always I think for a long
time there had been a general
understanding but
I think people underestimate
you know humans
I have to look it up but I'm pretty sure
there was some minor use for a long time
I mean if you go back to the Baghdad
battery what is what was what was the uh
what's the assumption that they were
doing electroplating
I think so a budget clay was a bunch of
clay pots yeah clay pots with vinegar or
or something acidic so vinegar wine you
could use lemon juice and they would put
copper wires in it yeah it'd be an iron
Rod sticking around the middle of the
pot wrapped with copper wire and that
would produce an electrical charge on
its own aliens because I gotta say I can
understand inventing bread but I can't
understand how someone accidentally
makes a battery
like a battery like the Baghdad battery
sounds like someone knew what a battery
was and said
like I'm trapped here in the desert with
little supplies I need to make some kind
of battery it's possible they had a cup
like a clay drinking vessel and they
were drinking wine and they shocked to
themselves like maybe there was copper
in it that's a shock yeah I think
ancient civilizations were a lot more
advanced than people realize some of
them forgotten lost whatever I agree
well knowledge has been lost yeah I
think that uh it's it's funny when
people talk about like the moon landing
and they're like we have Alex Stein on
the show and he's like how did we lose
the technology tab I'm like we lost tons
of Technology like the one the one
reference I have to bring up is that we
uh we couldn't build skyscrapers above
like eight floors or whatever when we
started expanding and building upward
because the heat would build up too much
yeah and we couldn't exhaust it fast
enough and then the air conditioner got
invented and now it's like now we can
but the crazy thing is they were they
were uh like native African tribes that
had built their their Hudson structures
to funnel heat up and out to keep the
inside cool when it was hot outside and
it's like that technology existed over
there and not over here now when we
build buildings they create like tunnels
that will pull because uh the hot air is
going to go up so you could they
actually create a system where it pulls
cold air from from the from the ground
and vents the hot air up up through the
roof so it reduces energy costs for
building skyscrapers but we we forgot
that not to mention the the Romans had
concrete That Could set underwater and
that's always the big one everyone
references tons of technology has been
lost I think that information is way
more valuable than people realize oh
yeah yes we've had such access to it as
Americans with libraries and internet
now but like you lose it once it's gone
like you might have a generation of
memory bro they had to but like this is
the crazy thing they had to invent the
idea of freedom
like so no but for real like that
certain ideas don't exist in certain
cultures and certain languages there's
um there was like I was reading a thing
a while ago about words that that have
complex meanings in certain cultures
that don't translate very well so in
like one African culture they have a
word they have a single word for the
feeling you get when you're longing for
someone but you are watching them long
for someone else and you know you'll
never have them they have like a single
word to explain that idea and it's like
for us we just I don't know I don't know
what you call it getting cucked I don't
know right it's like heartbreak you kind
of have a meme for it not even and then
uh uh in France they have the phrase the
call of the void and it's it's a
reference to when you're looking down
from a from from a great height and you
feel a desire to jump they just call it
the call of the Void it's so weird I
don't know if they actually I tried that
in the magazine thing is that a vacuum
pulling you towards it or something no
it's just like a voice the way that I
had heard it described is like you're
driving on a highway and you have that
instinct to just jerk the steering wheel
you'll feel it on the side bad idea how
about that that's the one that I read
the way they described it yeah I've
never experienced that I've had to like
looking down from a great height and
being like wow you feel like you can
just feel the jump it might be wind
pulling you because I'll feel it on the
subway track when a subway car goes
flying by I'll feel pulled towards
that's something that's all in your head
the call of the Void is a reference to
something specific yeah that people want
to jump from from like I'm not saying
jump to your death it's like it's a it's
like to just jump down under the
assumption that you're okay you're fine
so it's usually like you jump off a few
feet and you walk away but from Great
Heights you can't tell how high it is I
had a friend who broke her leg jumping
off the second story of a building
because she didn't realize how high it
was and it's like no there's no intent
to hurt yourself if you ever need to get
out of the Second Story do you hang and
then you drop but here's the crazy
here's the crazy thing about language
you know I remember the first time
someone told me oh this word can't be
translated I don't know how to translate
it and I'm like how do you not know how
to translate a word it's because the
idea in your mind doesn't have words in
another language I think they know the
word for love in North Korea there's no
word for snow in uh in the whatever
Hawaii whatever the Hawaiian languages
you know it's crazy to think about is
not just the words but how you perceive
the world based on language right so
someone who speaks someone can come into
this country for instance and learn
English but if they think in the world
and some like non-even Western language
they perceive
it existing on Earth in a totally
different way than we do you know
they're different people like
personalities change like people are
like oh I've heard like when someone
speaks Spanish they're like you're a
certain way when you speak Spanish but
when you speak English you're a
completely different way so so the main
reason I brought all this up is
the a lot of philosophical ideas that we
take for granted
heck the idea of zero as a number had to
be discovered yep and so there was a
period where if you went to if you went
to the average person and said let me
tell you about some maths let's say you
have let's say you're starting at zero
right they'll go huh look like zero like
let's say you have nothing they'll be
like huh yeah because there's no nothing
in reality it's a weird code it's just
like they're they don't know that they
don't understand that concept we grow up
we learn these things it becomes
commonplace to us so you know in today's
day and age you look at the philosophy
that was written
and these these great philosophers who
are coming up with these ideas and we're
kind of like it took you you had to
figure that one out I've always known
well it's because we're surrounded by
people who generally understand these
things that that information is is is is
given to us do you think that um
we're limited in our ability to think by
the language we know yes yeah so you
don't think we can think without
language
yes they're to a certain degree yes
there are different ways of thinking
they're they're uh and I'm not going to
pretend to know all of them or whatever
what I do know is and depends on the
person who's listening but I'm assuming
some people in here can think in words
images sounds some people can't think in
images some people think in uh they
describe it as just like raw thought
there's no there's no inner monologue
there's no voice
uh some people think and multi-track
more than more than one thing at a time
I I have this weird thing where I can be
daydreaming about my plans for a video
game while I'm talking and so I can be
literally just Auto piloting my ideas
and language while I'm imagining what
I'm gonna do when I go back to my video
it's like singing and playing guitar
kind of at the same time at Flow State
or your body but but this is right it's
also how you can you can write a song as
you're playing so it's it's how people
are freestyling their brain is planning
the words ahead before they say it so
it's multi-track freestyling different
thoughts at the same time that's cool so
the important thing is uh like the ideas
of Classical liberalism start to emerge
around what was like late 1600s 1700s
yeah when we start getting all those
ideas and it's hard it's crazy to think
that back then they did not have the
concept of like personal responsibility
and individual liberty like before the
United States for the most part I mean
granted there's Rome but after this
period with European colonialism and
European monarchy and stuff the general
idea was that if you were a world leader
it was it was because of Divine
Providence
God wills it divine right and then all
of a sudden you have the founding
fathers being like I kind of think we're
all equal and we're all people and
you're just making that up and we should
govern ourselves and they're like oh
arguably the first time that that
concept was actually like and put into
law was the Magna Carta and we talked
about the right card a couple days ago
um and that wasn't everybody that was
the actual
Lords trying to get some kind of uh
recognition from the King as equals I
don't think the actual peasants were
were written in the same way that the
landowners were but it was the first
step towards all people are created
equal in in the eyes of God or yeah you
know you don't really blew my mind the
first time I read about the discovery of
air
wow well yes because we we are raised in
a world where it is commonplace to
understand we live in a gaseous
atmosphere but there was this dude and
what they would do back in the day is
they had these brass balls with holes in
the bottom and a straw that comes up a
tube and what they would do is they
would put their they would take it dip
it in water put their thumb Over the
Hole pull it up and then let go and it
would pour the water over them so then
this one dude is like well you put it in
the water and then cover it what if I
cover it and then put it in the water
and when he did no water went inside and
he goes there's got to be something
there blocking the water from going in
and that's where it came up the idea of
air because because there's nothing like
you just can't see it you don't feel it
the wind is like some element they would
describe it as and this guy was like
there's air and then all of a sudden
there was this discovery and this
knowledge of people had like oh there is
something there isn't there so who
discovered transgenderism because I'd
like to go back in time and have a
peaceful word with them that's a long
time ago well let's talk about John
money and but to go back to ancient
knowledge and stuff but yeah who's the
other guy Kinsey Kinsey we got we you
got you got to say that stuff for
Sheamus but I just I I I'm sorry I just
love this idea we're talking about
Benjamin Franklin discovering
electricity you know he's not really
discovering it he's like I bet lightning
is electricity and then I just think
about that and I'm like wow do we really
take this stuff for granted because even
right now there's probably well it's a
fact that there's a bunch of really
stupid obvious things we don't know as
humans and in a hundred years they're
gonna be like they didn't know that like
you know X was psychic and it's going to
be so obvious to people in the future to
be like these morons took so long to
accept it like when you call your friend
and they're calling you the same moment
oops that it wasn't someone you didn't
know calling you it was the same person
you were calling just weird stuff you
know or where you can look at someone
and kind of you know what they're
thinking without them having to tell you
I mean maybe I don't know about all that
because it's like dreams and stuff like
dreams we haven't figured out what
dreams are yet they're going to tell in
the future they'll be like those idiots
I mean we have we have ideas but the
interesting thing about most of our
scientific ideas is that they tend to be
wrong isn't that crazy thing I love this
uh uh I was I was reading about how the
the
um
the way we view the human body and the
brain is based on the current version of
technology that is ubiquitous so before
uh you know 100 years ago when steam was
becoming this prominent thing the brain
was viewed as a pressure machine and it
worked through pressure and now that we
have computers it is viewed as a you
know where these people these Liberals
are like we're wet robots you know
that's all we are they're just basic and
the human brain is probably something
infinitely more profound than just to
call it a computer it's probably you
know we're it's going to be 100 years
from now and we're going to have Quantum
you know Quantum holographic you know uh
computational reality bending devices
and we're going to be like oh it's a
human brains a human brain is basically
just a function in Quantum uh you know
refraction device for manipulating
reality and they might still be wrong
and exactly and then it's gonna be 100
years later and they're like can you
believe can you believe they actually
thought that those crazy people everyone
knows the brain is just made of cheese
who knows but it is it is crazy to see
like how everything is always wrong like
we we they used to drink Mercury to
treat syphilis yeah it's and it's like
that was what you had to do and now
we're like well that's wrong
you have to dumb you're not dumb
yourself you have to think and live in
the terms of like your compatriot humans
at that period of History because like I
think of the subatomic spin of nature
these subatomic Spinners they're called
um you know quarks and things like that
and but if I talk to people as if your
brain is a bunch of quarks they're going
to look at me like I'm an idiot because
I'm it's too advanced they're like oh
you're born too early but how do we even
know ahead of your time is the
fundamental it's not it's just one of
the one we can see at the moment the
smallest particle we can currently see
at first we're like an atom can we split
the atom and then we did and then we
blew people up with it that's the funny
thing it's like a scientist is like
Eureka I've split the atom and then some
dude is like
this can kill a lot of people what if
you can split a lot of atoms isn't it
leads to the greatest like Innovations
and inventions it's wartime frequently
right all the time horrifically yes
that's why I I um in Europe there was
this uh one really
that was a great story I was reading
where
they're you know they have the archers
shooting at each other so what one side
did was they made it so that the what do
they call the notches or the knocks or
whatever they're called Natchez on the
arrows were really small
so that the drawstrings of their enemies
they could not use but the arrows the
larger spacings in them could be used on
their thinner so it's like all the
errors you shoot at us we can shoot back
but you can't shoot the arrows back at
us huh yeah
clever yeah that's pretty cool but
that's but the thing about Europe is
that you have Mediterranean abundance of
food which leads to population growth
and then you also have a finite amount
of space so when you get a large
population and then eventually nowhere
to go they start fighting over resources
which leads to Rapid uh uh competition
weapons and technology and tactical
developments and finally colonization
they eventually just build boats and say
we're getting out of here this is crazy
yeah one of the things about the stat
living in a status quo Society is that
taking risks and doing radical like in a
war you have very little choice you take
radical risks but we're kind of
disincentivized to do it in this culture
and I understand why because you want to
you know want it to stay balanced you
don't want someone to build new fusion
bomb right now because then everyone's
got a fusion bomb but it almost hinders
uh innovation in a way I think about it
I think you look at England and kind of
the anglo-sphere contributing probably a
lot of you know America and England a
lot of the world's technology today or
isn't vented here and uh you know you
kind of go back look at a place like
England right it's cold not a lot of
resources can't really do a whole lot so
you got to think creatively and I think
it's interesting how English creativity
seems to have contributed a lot to
history and then obviously you know the
largest Empire all that stuff Isaac
Newton I was reading about physics and
how Isaac Newton's discovery of like
allowed for long-range ballistics which
allowed the British Navy to dominate the
world they're long-range cannons they
could hit boats before the boats could
hit them and that was like prinkipia
Mathematica oh yeah
that was Newton's book
do you think that
like with England I'm sure there was
great minds there but you know with the
internet today we see that just a such
jump in information and knowledge
amongst humans do you think the fact
that they had such a far-reaching Empire
they just brought people together for
Better or For Worse and that bringing of
people together is just you shared ideas
you shared food recipes you know you
shared materials that you might not have
had access to and so that was what the
jump is in in our information as a
species I think rather than just England
being unique it's just an Empire will do
that that kind of when you have
different societies mixing together and
and you know interacting especially if
it's a peaceful interaction now granted
obviously
um not all of colonial uh British Empire
was uh was peaceful but there were
plenty of places that were interacting
with Britain in their colonies that were
not actually The Colony so you you know
like if you're in like the interior year
of Asia that wasn't you know uh British
colonies but you did have you know the
Silk Road and right all that kind of
stuff and that really does uh help
to facilitate uh learning from you know
learning because you're interacting with
other cultures and and one culture that
might discover something uh
uh cause they don't have a taboo that
another culture does might be able to
pass on the knowledge you know there's a
lot of taboos that that cultures have
like whether whether it be types of food
or you have to dress this way whether it
be religions or certain behaviors that
will get you killed in the Amazon but
won't get you killed in the desert and
stuff like that so it's like those kind
of interactions really do help uh
societies to to progress there's this
idea that uh it's not the strongest of
the humans that will survive but the
ones that are the most adaptable to
change that might actually be a Darwin
quote and so I'm wondering like the
Romans were extremely adaptable they
would conquer and take people's
technology and then call it Roman
technology and then move on and I wonder
if we're in his place in the world right
now where communism is a technology that
people think
maybe is they think that being the most
adaptable like we we're in a culture War
to decide to show people what what they
should adapt into I think in communism
to a lot of people looks like a good
looks like an easy path out and it's
like
hey is it but you were shaking your head
immediately when I brought up the word
communism like you don't think it's the
right adapt I don't think it's because
it's totalitarian it's it's the problem
the the root problem with Communism is
that it's totalitarian you don't get to
have another opinion and if you have the
wrong opinion then you end up either you
know nowadays it's cancel culture but
back in you know so my buddy Zoltan the
guitar player from from uh Five Finger
Death Punch he grew up in Hungary okay
when it was Communist and you know he
would say something and his parents
would be like shut up you're gonna get
someone you know you're gonna get
they're gonna come and take you away
um he's a he's a very intelligent guy
he's gifted he was put into this the the
smart people schools when he was young
he was taken away from his family and
stuff and you know you get that kind of
stuff you don't get to you know make
decisions on your own and stuff so it's
it's you you don't actually have the
option to decide to do something else
they will decide what's which ultimately
is a a lack of adaptation if you can't
adapt in a system if it's totalitarian
and you're unable to adapt then the
system will falter and fail it's not
about it's not about adaptation it's
about uh the the inability to make
decisions on your own so there's no
creative process there's no markets
there's no uh there's no exchange of
ideas it's this is the way it is and
that means there's no growth in your in
your Society there's no no uh progress
in your in your markets and stuff like
that so it's it's all bad I think
communism in many ways is kind of an
example of falling victim to change
instead of adapting to it because you
look at even the social situation where
communism originates from right
Industrial Revolution Europe's changing
very fast there's the good there's the
bad and a lot of people
because you know you look at a place
like Russia right that was obviously the
first uh Communist Revolution there
because they Tucker Carlson brings us up
a lot because they did not properly
adapt to industrialization the changing
world in the right way what happened
right they fell to the Bolsheviks the
Tsar you know fell out of favor and all
that stuff and with most communist
revolutions around the world arguably
even including our own right now it
really comes down to a failure to
properly adapt to change and then the
change basically just destroys you right
and I think with America you could point
to a lot of things maybe the failure to
adapt to the internet and Technology
there's an argument to be made there
right that's definitely accelerated the
kind of left-wing push of the culture
and all that probably a lot of other
factors
um yeah I think it's that you have the
older generation that keeps ignoring it
as the internet starts growing so if you
look back to the Advent of the internet
you have uh people saying it's a fad
it's never going to take off it's
nothing and then you have its expansion
young people have completely embraced it
and started using it uh I'm a little kid
we had we had compuser on dos then we
ended up with you know AOL and so I'm
using the internet I grew up on it these
older people keep just maintaining their
status quo systems because it's too hard
to move their monolithic structures and
this happens for a lot of Industries but
with Communications it results in a
generation that speaks a different
language yeah and then all of a sudden
you're going to get a cultural
bifurcation like what we have now the
people who believe in Freedom use the
internet and like posting memes and the
Communists who fell victim to the
algorithmic manipulation for money who
are now psychotic and these World Views
can't come together you look
the story of that girl who was raised by
wolves or whatever it's not literally
Raised by Wolves but the wild girl and
uh she never she could never learn
English
she never learned language and by the
time she was like a teenager and they
find her or whatever they try saying
like here's how to speak she could only
ever Grunt and say basic things like
food
yeah hungry and could never actually
have complex conversations because the
brain never developed so what happens is
if you have someone who grows up in the
Communist world of algorithmic
manipulation and someone who grows up in
a freedom meme loving bulletin board
system world of the internet the hacker
culture stuff these two World Views will
never come together and you're not going
to be able to explain to the Communists
why their worldview doesn't work because
their brains are wired to be controlled
and be commanded that's why some people
are literally NPCs right we always use
that term non-playable character but
it's true yeah it's true these people
have been programmed through uh through
schools and through uh I think mostly
through school
until they go to college so they're
spending their life from five years old
let's say preschool four years old till
22 maybe 24 26 depending what degree
they're getting where they're always
just told what to do and in their life
and their brain and everything their
brain is constructed around life is I
will be told what to do and I will do it
and then you have other people who are
like I will find my own way and figure
life out on my own
you can't convince someone whose brain
is hardwired to be commanded that they
should break free and be independent you
can't it's not completely true I'm
saying it's very very difficult and it's
painful for people that's why Brandon
struck talks about the story of when he
finally got red pill didn't realize what
was going on it physically hurt him dude
it's so interesting to think that every
society could get to a point where it
needs to adapt to modern tech and if it
doesn't it falls into totalitarianism
and then it will eruption Anarchy or
chaos something's gonna happen and then
it'll just be an explosion of pain and
violence until they reform a new Society
to get to a place where they need to
adapt again and are they going to make
the same mistake again like you said the
internet you know we should be first of
all we should be looking at this and be
like oh this is all able to be spying on
me and I'm using it every day I need the
software code all of it that should be
we should be adapted to that already we
should be using this to govern ourselves
that should be done we should be local
governance we should be moving tax money
around locally deciding where tax money
goes I'm like what are we waiting on Big
Daddy to do it for us that's
totalitarianism right but you have half
the country that wants Big Daddy to tell
them what to do
yeah your mind is like a muscle if
you're not working it out it's going to
be a shriveled sad piece of meat so
that's what I took from what like Tim
was saying that these people they're on
autopilot they're in the Lazy Boy from
the time they're born they get the
tablet they get YouTube they've got
algorithms they turn on the smart TV
they don't have to think so that muscle
is not being worked you know what though
I think there's an interesting argument
to be made that doesn't every society
have that right like how many people in
any society in any point in human
history
more than 20 to 30 percent of the
population truly thinks for themselves
right I think a lot of times some people
are naturally kind of followers and
leaders that's why you have both I think
the problem now is that now that they
have control of you know internet and
everything like that you can very easily
manipulate the followers now to you know
go towards the side of evil whereas say
you know I don't know 1950s whatever
conservative decade we want to look at
most people back then probably weren't
thinking for themselves either but you
had people first of all you have the
internet so manipulation wasn't as easy
as it is now but I think probably you
also had a lot of people who uh were
kind of more responsible paternalistic
cultural leaders that weren't trying to
push the destruction of their own
country onto the people you see Hitler
used the radio for sure to manipulate
and control people and push them towards
either lens that's radio change things
it's huge yeah and when you play
Civilization which I really that's like
the biggest change in the game radio
when when radio is developed it Alters
the human species like beyond measure
the ability to communicate across long
distances the creation of the uh it's
when they they built the eye of Sauron
all of a sudden you have a singular
broadcast tower telling you what to
think and feel and this is the authority
and everyone wants to hear before it was
like Word of Mouth everything was very
local you go to your church you'd hear
what people were saying you'd look at
the local paper but they were competing
papers and the newspapers were getting
big but once radio happens all of a
sudden you know people start getting
these these boxes that are telling them
and for a long time in the United States
you had only a couple networks and then
they all marched in lockstep as to what
was true and what you must believe and
that's the thing is even in America it's
only been the past few decades where
people even question what they see on TV
right when Walter concrete went out and
said the Vietnam war is bad basically
the country believed it right during
World War II I don't think anyone really
questioned what they heard on the news
media the radio and so I think even in
this country it's probably still a
problem you know and historically was of
course that's the internet breaks it and
now we're going back to how people more
localized communities the problem is
they're not physical they're right
they're they're social yeah well what it
is is uh you'd have a region that would
have a culture and a way of speaking and
a kind of food based on what was there
and they and their ideas were based on
the world they lived in now with the
internet you have people you'll have a
conservative living next to a liberal
the conservative has his community
online the liberal has their Community
online and next door to each other they
don't like each other
yeah it used to be geography like
dictated your culture in a huge way it
doesn't matter anymore you've got people
in the United States that agree with
Communism I mean it's crazy that would
have never happened right 30 years ago I
remember 30 years ago I would I had
friends in my neighborhood that I didn't
like like kids that were mean kids that
I just didn't want to be around but that
was who was in my neighborhood so that's
who I was around and I suffered some
abuse because of it so like in a way
it's better that I don't have to
interact with those people even if
they're next door I can get online and
talk to the cool smart people but that's
a part of life too exactly yeah and now
you can avoid that situation and if I
you know avoiding it's probably a
problem probably causing a rift right
like you're supposed to interact with
people you disagree with right and
supposed to figure out how to get along
with people you don't get along exactly
exactly
why do you say supposed to
I think it's just part of our Evolution
what's got us to where we're at part
part of the American dream and part of
the founding fathers they all kind of I
like their how they would argue and I
guess I have a different take on on what
is evolution and then because I I don't
think that the human race is has really
considerably evolved in the past 200
years you think you think I'm I'm kind
of off about evolution is kind of off in
general yeah it's basically a little
wrong I think that Evolution
um you know it requires an outside force
like so you don't like evolution is G is
genes that have produced an adaptation
to something that is an outside uh Force
so like the the way they figure that
eyes evolved there were cells that were
you know when you when we were without
eyes and and stuff in in uh in the water
and stuff the cells that happen to be uh
receptive to light that could actually
just see just light and dark right those
are the ones that there were ended up
being the ones that would could give
more likely to survive yeah more likely
to survive and so without some kind of
outside
influence you don't get an evolution the
evolution of the eye is an awesome video
you guys should watch I I don't know the
exact I think if you search evolution of
the eye explained you'll get the video
I'm probably referring to but they break
down how you have these cells and it's a
competition they're just all competing
for the free energy available some of
these cells are being hit by light and
the light is they're more receptive to
it this gives them an advantage in data
they're now getting a binary set of data
light or dark which allows them to see
if something so basically now if it's
just dark you can't see where the free
the the free food the food is but now
with Light added to the mix you'll see
dark in a pool of light indicating
potential free energy this maybe it was
only a 0.1 percent increase in the free
energy acquired by these cells but it
resulted in them being more successful
over a long period of time what ends up
happening is as single as multicellular
organisms evolve that you get like
dimples because a dimple allows light to
to hit from multiple angles giving you
more depth and understanding of where
the light is coming from then you get
the reason there's two is because it
creates uh uh a depth a depth of field
so now you can perceive how far away an
object might be so all of these things
are just evolved because it's the most
natural thing within our system in terms
of how light operates
it's
super smart and also like one of the
arguments uh against like
humans ability to interact with reality
so there's there are philosophers that
say you can't actually know what's real
because you have your brain is actually
interpreting the things that you say
yeah and the the argument against that
is
without a an existing world out there to
perceive you don't get evolution
like without an existing world to
interact with so that means I don't
think that disproves Brandon of fat no
no not bringing that I'm talking about
um the the idea that we can't no there
is no reality so you right that we can't
actually know what reality is that's an
argument that's made but the fact that
we can we can that we've evolved means
that there is an out there is a reality
out there for us to have responded to so
so I I was having a conversation with
someone a few years ago out in Vegas I
think it was in Vegas and uh the
question I asked was if I take this
phone right here and I throw it at that
window what will happen
what will happen again it'll hit the
window and bounce off make a noise maybe
leave a dent Mark in the wood or
something all right a definitive answer
and there's other acceptable answers it
will break the window and fly outside
the it'll bounce off and the phone will
shatter the phone will break into a
couple different pieces we'll land in my
hand because I have lightning or you'll
catch it and so the point I made was
are you thinking about your
circumstances in terms of this is what
will happen are you thinking about
things in terms of the most likely thing
to happen or are you thinking are you
thinking about things in terms of
there's a 10 chance that'll do this a 70
chance it'll do this a 23 chance it'll
do this and a 47 chance it'll do this
and then you're creating contingencies
based on the probabilities I usually
think contingencies but I found people
think I'm psychotic if I talk in
contingency so I've got to pick really
quickly the the most likely one and kind
of
flush it out and see if it's psycho what
I mean to say is
you will you you need to figure out when
it's appropriate to look at a
circumstance of someone wants to throw a
phone at a window instead of just making
the Assumption it will do X but to is to
consider
what are the probabilities and
possibilities and then what what are
your plans in the event of A B C or D
but it's not appropriate to do that in
every single circumstance sometimes if
you're in a burning building and you're
like let's figure this one out you're
probably just gonna have to go for the
first the most like get out of the
building but there there may be
alternate paths with higher rates of
success you just don't know but you've
gotta like it's outside the box I
actually tweeted this out yesterday uh
when you're thinking outside the box
have about 60 to 90 different possible
outcomes in your mind you don't have to
adhere to any of them but just know that
there are those many and that's when
you're out thinking outside the box but
there are situations like you're just
saying burning building you don't have
time you're in the Box you need to get
out so you you do what you got to do
with you what you got we're going to
Super chats so if you haven't already
would you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends and head over to
timcast.com become a member to support
our work directly let's read what you
all have to say we got culture abduction
says first and shout out to the Dallas
mayor who switches sides here here Clint
Torres is back with another howdy people
Jeremiah D Mack Roberts says
starscapechronicles.com new Sci-Fi
Universe very cool
very cool I've uh I've completed my
first run through of um Baldur's Gate
now I'm wondering if I should play it
was a Starfield star field yes it sounds
like but it's woke sounds like yeah
there's some woke elements but you said
Baldur's Gates got some of those
elements too well Baldur's Gate has the
you can create a character who has like
a male face a female body a deep male
voice identifies as non-binary and like
it so if you try to randomize your
character you're gonna get a purple
haired masculine like dude with boobs
sounds like it's similar level as
Baldur's Gate um but it's fun but the
game itself isn't I mean I guess the
fact I'm pretty sure in Baldur's Gate
everyone's gay
no I'm not saying that to be mean like
like all the characters are homosexual
or they're all bi well I guess pan
sexual is a better way to put sexual
yeah because
and it's if it's funny if you think
about video games they have to do it
that way because of the general idea is
that you can customize your own
character to be anything and you should
have an option to romance your
characters they have no choice but to
make it so all the characters are just
banging everybody and don't care like
you know what sucks I grew up my
childhood playing a lot of GTA I've
waited now 10 years for the next game
and it's like one of the things in my
life that's the last video game I'm
gonna play I'm gonna be adult right it's
just GTA 6. and I know at this point the
fact that it's probably gonna come out
2027 2028 I know exactly how it's going
to be well what they're doing the
character's female now yeah for the
first time it's going to be a female
character can I guys spoil a little bit
of something from Starfield sure it's
not major at all okay so there's this
little note that you find and because
the game was delayed there's a guy so
excited to play the game he had cancer
never got to play the game so in his
honor they put a little note in the game
that you can go and find and collect and
it's just like happy hunting or happy
exploring the universe it's really sad
but that's what reminded me if it's like
these games like really people get so
excited and yeah so in uh World of
Warcraft or something I've done this I
think on multiple occasions where uh
I think in burning Crusade they did this
someone who played a lot died of cancer
and so the character
became an NPC in the city that you could
go and talk to and interact with so like
immortalized it one day but with AI
you'll be actually still talking to the
real version yep that's creepy Let's uh
let's read some more let's read some
more Super chats where are we at
uh
Melinda Lou says has the team uh
considered virtual tickets to the Miami
event yes so I don't want to say too
much just yet but um we're we're
currently navigating how we're going to
do the live portion of it and there is a
decent probability the the live show
will just be the whole show the whole so
this is a Friday night show instead of
doing the normal Friday night show it
will be a members only for the full
thing but this will include the pre-show
that this way we can do we can do the
pre-show the comedy the show and the
after show show all in one go
but we're not completely sure that
that'll be the way we'll do it and then
what we would do is we would immediately
upload the podcast to all podcast
platforms we would then put the clips on
uh on YouTube like normal but the issue
is
if we're going to have all these awesome
people the last thing we want to do is
be like we're doing the the normal this
is a YouTube show and so here's nah we
want to we want to have we want Alex
Stein to be able to just like we want to
own the show and I have to worry about
anything and make it the most
entertaining entertaining thing
imaginable which means we probably have
to control it but we're not 100 the
general idea for now was pre-show is not
live it's only at the venue the show
will be live on YouTube as per normal
and then the after show is you know at
the venue only and then I thought yeah
but members who can't travel like we got
to figure something out so the the idea
might be just like the whole Miami event
will be available for members on
timcast.com again we'll have to figure
that one out not 100 sure that's the way
we're gonna do it though but uh I don't
know I don't know we'll we'll see we
will see we will see and uh yeah let's
read some more dude it'd be cool to have
a 3D camera on stage that you could
watch from
if you have like special access and be
there on stage with everybody like
there's no way we can set that up I mean
we we might be able to 360 cams yes we
can do it but Bill like I have like I
don't think Rumble has the capabilities
for 360 camera ingestion yeah you would
have to do something alternate stream
yeah YouTube does so so yes it exists
and I've done them before 360 degree
live streams but they fell out of pop
like no one cares to do them anymore we
used to carry the the monopod with the
360 camera it would stream and then you
chose what to look at which is cool but
super low res it could be cool to do
like have one of the chairs be a 360 cam
you know we could do in that chair we
just set it up well we could just record
every episode and then upload the 360
Live podcast watch it if you want put it
on Rumble because if you have goggles on
it you can like turn and look at the
guys that are talking it's so awesome
yeah yeah but the the real the real goal
is to do stereoscopic three uh 360 which
is the it's hard to do
but you have uh a sphere with two
cameras so it's not one camera it's two
for every for every camera you double it
up so that way you can create depth of
field so for someone who's putting on a
VR headset and looking around you
actually can see depth but it doesn't
work perfectly because the cameras don't
move so there's AI building gaps you
know whatever Let's uh let's read some
more
Devin Grissom says Tim I think we need
to see James Lindsay back on the show
with Phil
I'd love to hang out with Jim I haven't
had a chance to meet him in person but
uh we have corresponded via the Internet
and he is well that's very friendly guy
well I just got a tweet at him tell Jim
come on come on the show we're talking
about Jim degrowth you're in DC a lot
come on we should do a culture war with
James Lindsay yeah would you want to do
it would you I would totally let's do it
all right what do we have Skyler Pearson
says Tim you should look up Publius
Claudius pulcher and the sacred chickens
You're Gonna Love It I I thoroughly
enjoyed this show with Matt Gates last
night my favorite rep thank you to you
and your team for all that you do uh you
know we had Ami Horowitz scheduled and
Matt Gates's team said hey we wanted to
we don't know if there's any
availability and I'm like oh yo Matt can
come whenever he wants not not only do
we need to like like get the opportunity
to hear what he's talking about with
this continue resolution it's a
tremendous opportunity for the American
people I'm a big fan of Matt Gates he he
is he's the the he's actually doing
things
I'm just you know as soon as we leave
the show I'm going to my girlfriend I'm
like Matt Gates may have just shut down
Omnibus spending I'm hoping he wins this
this is crazy that would be amazing and
it's just like who else is doing stuff
like this no no credit to Marjorie
Taylor green Thomas Massey there's
there's a handful of really great people
but I think Matt Gates is just doing
doing the most he's an aggressive
Communicator he likes building
coalitions he's good at it I know and
I'm impressed with his his uh uh he is
tactful he's he even talked about you
know uh he was talking about the uh he's
worked with AOC on um it was the stock I
think it was him and AOC on this like
stopping stock training within uh
insider trading stuff so I think he does
a great job but um I do feel bad for AMI
because it's always it's always rough
when it's like you book a guest and then
it's like the air will be sucked out of
the room by this very big very important
show we've got someone coming in who's
in the middle of this big news story I
will also add though I got a a shout out
from um
uh Richie McGinnis we were on MSNBC they
used clips of the show to like talk
about the Republicans or whatever oh
nice yeah I'm like hey man I'll take it
it's an honor and a privilege to be able
to get you know first-hand view of yeah
and breakdown of what's going on with
the with Congress
all right let's go back to where we are
Remington says Styx is back in the
States are you going to have him on oh
is he
so there are uh a couple individuals who
have made it to the states
so um I don't I don't we usually don't
announce anything because
um then when someone cancels it sucks we
do we are trying to get sticks X and Ham
around the show we have been trying to
get stick sex and hammer on the show
forever since the show began he's like
well I'm a big fan he's a very rational
very smart guy and he has great content
and
um I think Carl Benjamin is also in the
states currently he's in Florida he put
up a picture of a horrible pizza and I
don't
I don't approve I don't care that you're
from England and that like you're not
used to good looking food that pizza was
an Abomination zelenski's here too right
now oh yeah oh wow
uh I'm a I'm a huge fan of oh that awful
Pizza it's gross right it's half
Hawaiian half pepperoni and it's like
cut wrong was it good for him he he
liked it bro well I mean you know what's
crazy Florida has so many New Yorkers
and yet I've never had good pizza in
that state really that's that does
that's
so there is a rumor there there are
people that say that the water in New
York yes I've heard that Connecticut is
is why the pizza's so good it's it's
three things
the water
the uh the the air altitude and the um
the flower they use so there was a place
I went to in Florida that advertised New
York Pizza and they actually said we
import our water and our flour from New
York and cook it to simulate the
humidity and conditions of a typical of
New York on average so it's really I I
think uh New York is New York sea level
but then there's also like the humidity
conditions the average temperature and
so you're in Florida it's much more
humid you have to control for these
things to really try and simulate how
New York Pizza comes out I have had
pizza across the whole country every
state I guarantee at some point some
Club has just thrown pizza after the
show right Chicago pizza is the best but
not I am not talking about deep dish
it's different kind of pizza than New
York Pizza too not deep dish I am
talking about real Chicago Pizza which
is it's a it's it's a thin-ish crust
it's the the crust is probably twice as
thick as your average New York and it's
firm
I don't really know how to describe it
it is it is and it's cut into squares
and this is how we had all of our pizza
growing up the crust doesn't rise so you
don't get like a New York Pizza the back
of the pizza is big and then it's flat
and then right it rises a little bit
Chicago Pizza doesn't do that it it's
baked and it like stays as it is then
then it's like the sauce the cheese is
really thick they're cutting the squares
and it's a thick square piece that's how
we have Chicago Pizza Chicago pizzas
have you guys tried Andy's Pizza that's
in the area yet so they won 2021's
world's best pizza award yeah I've been
meaning to try it and apparently they
want it with a cheese pizza oh we gotta
get Dave Portnoy out here I mean he's
doing pizza fast yeah Dave just did a
just did a a review of my buddy's Pizza
um up in uh in Connecticut uh fuco Pizza
it's great give it a good review yeah
you gave him I think you gave like an
eight five did you see that video where
the guy came out screaming at him yeah
yeah
what happened what he's like he does the
Pizza reviews and he came out and the
store owner came out and started
screaming at him or something like
insulting him and then he started
talking talking with people who are
outside and they're like I love day boy
he's great and he's like what's going on
dude I've just seen people no no he he
tried to go to the cops the business
owner because he was standing on the
sidewalk and the cops were cool with him
you know they were friends with him and
stuff so
just because he's he's a liberal but
also I guess the business owner's claim
is that Dave Portnoy is bad for small
business
which I don't understand
here's the thing too is even if you give
a place a bad Pizza review okay Barr
stole people on the Internet won't go
there but it's not gonna hurt your
current existing business not you know
what I mean David we can only bring
business because he knows he's got bad
Pizza yeah bro if I have a pizza place
and Dave shut up I'll be like please bro
tell the people about my pizza yeah he's
gonna be like it's pretty good man even
if he said it's not the best pizza but
it's like a seven or an eight I'd be
like yes if you live in the area too you
would be like okay also like fortnite
was doing all that stuff during covet to
help all the small businesses
didn't he say he had too much parmesan
is that what it was yeah yeah it's like
too much par man I don't like it I it
two days ago but honestly it was an
average New England area I like I like
David he he had mincy's back when they
fight him for BS reasons he has that's
that's good yeah that Washington Post
journalist trying to cut do a hit piece
on him so he called her directly and
recorded and uploaded it on Twitter for
this two days ago highly recommend it's
like a master class in how you deal with
this stuff go on the offensive and they
and she admitted that she was just
trying to goad people and then published
the story anyway and he's like how how
it's amazing that the state of
Journalism you can get someone on the
phone admitting that they're making up
the story and pushing it and then still
run the story anyway
I think now is a good time to quote
Michael malice the job is not done until
the average corporate journalist is
looked at in the same way that a tobacco
lobbyist is he is correct he is correct
let's read some more
all right dark Hal Hound says dark dark
hellhound it says dark hell hound New
Jersey voted Menendez back in after he
was indicted well you wrote indicated
but indicted in 2013 for bribery fraud
and false statements most people in New
Jersey will vote for the person with the
D next to the name yep
and when you go and talk to them I wish
I'd love to believe there's a conspiracy
but bro
I have lived near these people I have
sat down and played poker with these
people I have gone to bars and spoken to
them at bars and they have no idea what
the they are talking about and you'll
say something like
you'll be like do you have any concerns
about you're stubborn about it too well
no like you'll go to somebody back you
you uh you just you oh like you're
wearing an I voted thing it's like you
vote uh what did you go like I voted for
Menendez I'm like do you have any
concerns about the fraud and like the
accusations of underage girls and we'll
go the what
and I was like oh dude politics is
busted man it's never a good policy to
say oh we want to remove voting rights
from people but man people abuse the
hell out of their right to vote right
they are irresponsible with it there is
they do no they do no actual put no
actual effort into looking to see if
what they've heard on Comedy Central is
actually true they are it is just clown
you know what's so sad about it too is
New England and I guess by extension I'm
not gonna but that area of the country
is where the American Revolution
originated from and you can still see
some of that attitude in the people in
the sense that they're so stubborn and
belligerent and you can tell how hey
these people's ancestors picked up guns
the problem is the energy is directed
all in the wrong direction right when
you think about if New England or energy
of today could be directed toward hey
you know I'm not with what's going on in
the country we're going to protect
American tradition but instead it's like
yes I'm going to stubbornly stand up
like the guy in the Dave Portner video
and fight you over uh the rights of you
know gay black transgender children to
you know get mastectomies at 14. you
know but I'll fight you for that bro you
know that kind of thing that's that's
the problem the energy is in the wrong
direction all right Tyrion says be
careful with an orgy of evidence this is
the passport and the wreck of 9 11. I
think the 150s and 20s is because a
single Bank only has so much cash on
hand also why hide it in clothing I
think it's a fair point too someone said
that uh Menendez was speaking out
against the Iran deal and then all of a
sudden indictment drops maybe that's it
I do not trust these people man I don't
I don't I don't trust Menendez but I
gotta I gotta be honest
if you've got you you can what was the
Jack Sparrow quote he's a he's a
dishonest man but you can trust him
because you can trust him to be
dishonest yeah and something like that
and that's how I view politicians across
the board except for maybe like a
handful of Libertarians right maybe like
one Democrat maybe like seven seven
Republicans but the the the sdny
it's just like you can't even trust them
to be dishonest properly they are
completely amoral crackpots I would not
put it past them to go after even a
Democrat because a Democrat was falling
in line in fact I would expect that so
yeah Menendez I view what you know like
the the idea that he would play politics
so that he can get favors that's the
kind of dishonesty expect from a
Menendez bribery and these kind of
charges are up there and then you look
at the going after Donald Trump which is
you know I guess you can call one
neutral evil and then uh what sdny is
doing is like I don't know it's abject
evil
like I I know that Menendez is like
these these politicians are going to do
things like insider trading they're
going to say hey if you fund this thing
for me I'll fund this thing for you and
like they're gonna have a buddy come to
them say hey look man my company needs
this thing done don't worry we'll get it
through committee
whether or not he would take gold bars
in exchange for that is is is a leap so
maybe maybe
but I'm going to say it like sdny going
after Trump all the coming out
of New York is so just egregious I don't
believe I don't trust it and a good
point on origin of evidence I I think
they're definitely after Menendez for a
reason whatever reason that is it never
comes it's similar to the Russell Brand
thing I guess I mean who knows if he did
it or not but yeah but according to
their story they knew Hollywood or in
the entertainment industry must have
known about this so many decades ago but
now suddenly because he is causing
problems for them now allegedly
according to them suddenly they care
suddenly they bring this up I just don't
believe it I mean we we talked with uh
FBI whistleblowers this morning on the
culture war and I'm like hey we have
instances of identity theft fraud and
swattings and we get no law enforcement
uh accountability or anything and
they're like of course not enough money
well it's not that I think that a good
portion of it is they operate As Weapons
of of the agenda narrative the cathedral
Etc yeah and I think everybody would
agree if you are an obstacle in any way
and your obstacle and you're out of the
picture and they'll come out and they'll
find a reason and if you're a regular
person you say hey I'm under attack
they'll say you have we don't care what
this this thing has no impact on us
I did get the vibe that the 400 going
after him for 400k seems like not well
that's not that much I mean like but it
is it's felony territory yeah I'm torn
like I don't like the government
Prosecuting people but I also don't like
politicians and I like politicians you
know getting prosecuted so I'm I'm torn
well I think it could be true and he's
guilty of all of it but they only care
because of a certain reason you know
what I mean that's also a possibility
because yeah it crossed my mind how many
politicians are technically guilty of
bribery probably all of them this is a
girl right here uh paracelsus undirect
says the Chinese couldn't capitalize on
gunpowder because the steel in the East
is crap it's Western steel that changed
gunpowder interesting that is an awesome
fact perhaps that was perhaps that is
why they could make the the powder but
they could not contain it and direct the
energy properly I put them I I mean I
know Japan has is is well known for the
steel and the swords the katanas and
stuff like that so
I think I think it really I think a lot
of it has to do with China so Japan had
uh uh
Japan's an island so the fighting and
and competition there is fierce with
North with the Americas with Africa and
with uh Eastern Europe you have such a
large large land masses that when
conflict arose people could flee so this
is true of animals
um the the uh Burling animals tend to be
the most vicious badgers for instance
because they dig their way into a hole
stuck and they're stuck and so if a
predator comes if they don't fight they
die so what happens is so let's say you
have a bunch of badgers and half of them
are really nice and have them are really
mean nice ones are all dead with birds
they fly away which is why birds aren't
aggressive they don't attack you for the
most part but I've seen have you ever
seen a bird attack somebody
they can't fly now and then they feel a
little more but I mean I've seen someone
walk near a tree with eggs and the bird
jumps out and starts like flapping
around their head and pecking at them
and stuff and I'm like whoa Bird's
pissed I saw a squirrel attack somebody
once too that's crazy it looks like in
1856 Henry Bessemer developed a method
to reduce the carbon content in Iron
which led to Modern Steel
so the thousand years before that I
don't know why it didn't take off what
what advancements they had well I don't
think steel casings for a while read
about the history of guns Just barrels
the crazy thing is how long it took to
get the modern revolver it's like
somebody so so they got muskets and then
some guy's like what if I have like a
rotating cylinder with we can pre-load
all of the uh the the the the you know
the balls and the powder and what what
the way it worked is same as a flint
lock and after it fired you would hand
crank it and then set it again and fire
and then hand crank it and then
eventually they developed percussion cap
which is pre-loaded but then you put
percussion caps little metal caps that
have primer in them and you stick them
over the holes and then the hammer hits
it sparking into the chamber and firing
it and then eventually I think it was
some French dude who was like why don't
we just put it all in one thing like put
the primer and and the casing and the
bullet all in one then you can just put
it in the gun and shoot it and take it
out and put it one in and
and then it but it was like a hundred
years or something it was crazy who gets
credit it's the Portuguese gets credited
with modern Firearms right is that right
no I don't think so I think the
cartridge was a French dude cartridge it
sounds like a French word yeah French
gunsmith Casimir Le foshu invented the
cartridge 1836 the cartridge yeah crazy
and then uh uh see that's pre-civil War
30s yeah 1830s and then in the Civil War
the Confederates were still using muzzle
loaded rifles yeah the union was as well
Battle of Gettysburg changed the game
because the Union soldier started using
uh I guess you I guess you'd call it uh
breach breach loaded shells I'm sorry
breach loaded cartridges paper
cartridges so it had the bullet it had
the powder and it was wrapped in paper
and you would basically break action and
then they would stick it in the back and
then close it and then they could fire
with a percussion cap and it they were
they were 10 times fast in the
Confederates you know you know what's
crazy is uh the union had access to the
1860 Henry which was a lever action
rifle right I think one of the first or
the first ever invented uh and in theory
they probably could have mass adapted to
it which back then it'd be like even
sure about that yeah by giving every
infantry man a machine gun 1860 1860
Henry's the first
um like major lever action lever action
in America yeah was it invented in 1860
I think that's why it's called the 1860
hundred but the Civil yeah yeah and then
there's 1866 after that wow but I guess
the union wouldn't adapt it on I think
some Sharpshooters had it actually but
the union wouldn't adapted on a mass
level because they were scared people
were going to waste bullets wow which
whoa which you think how differently the
war could have gone and I think I'm
pretty sure that actually carried over
the same logic kind of screwed us up in
Vietnam too the beginning because there
was 1731 Henry Rifles used by the
government in the Civil War and it was a
point of Pride to have one yeah wow so
in Vietnam they were using like m1s or
something right because they had the M1
M1A M14 uh and the Soviets are the early
in the war the Viet Cong actually I
think out classed us because they had
AKs already but the thinking in the
military brass even then was oh the
soldiers are all going to waste ammo if
we you know give them a lot of yeah all
right everybody if you haven't already
would you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the
share with your friends become a member
at timcast.com to support the work we're
doing all of our cultural Endeavors
really do appreciate you can follow the
show at timcast IRL you can follow me
personally at timcast Vince you want to
shout anything out uh yeah just be sure
to subscribe to my YouTube channel just
Vince Dao that's my name Dao and uh you
know you can look that name up on other
socials as well but YouTube so yeah go
subscribe to the channel right on I am
fill that remains on Twix I am Phil that
remains official on the old Instagram uh
the band is All That Remains uh you can
find us on Spotify Apple music Pandora
uh Amazon music You Know YouTube you
know the internet thank you Rockstar
cheers uh I'm Ian Crossland you can
follow me at Ian cross on Twix or any
other social network uh happy to oblige
Vince Dow TV on Twix that's Twitter
Vince Now TV get over here Elon so I
stopped making fun of you love you guys
see you later I didn't know what Twix
Brett's been doing that all week I had
no idea what twist I got it from Brett
okay
um yeah huge shout out to Carter banks
for pressing buttons all week you're a
rockstar man uh you guys can follow me
at Kellen PDL and get your Miami tickets
you have one week left do it
all right everybody thanks for hanging
out we'll be back uh next uh we'll be
back on Monday and we'll see y'all then